is he running the universe as a man
again I cannot answer that so one thing
is don't misquote me I'm not saying that
he didn't run the universe I'm not
saying that at
all what bro what are you talking about
man and so during that time when he was
on Earth we understand that the father
and the Holy Spirit they were really
running the universe they were really
running the universe we understand that
Jesus growing up had to learn things
correct
so we understand that at at certain
points that you know Jesus was not
running the universe Jesus was not
running the universe he yielded that um
he yielded I guess the keys or the
rights to the entire Cosmos to his
father do that make
sense amen
amen amen
amen
[Applause]
amen well hey there thank you for being
here especially if this is your first
time with us Adventist or
otherwise now folks I have mentioned
this before but I am forced to reiterate
this for both our regulars as well as
those that might be new here answering
adventism is not an e drama platform if
you are one of these people in the
modern day that lives chronically online
you will know what I am referring to
unfortunately that is the type of thing
that performs best on YouTube but
regardless that isn't why I started this
nor is that what this platform is going
to turn into again for those that are
new we are an educational platform for
the Christian church that is educating
Christians on the theological dangers of
adventism and there's a two-fold aspect
to that to strengthen up the body of
Christ which I so happen to love while
at the same time equip that body to be
able to reach adventis with the truth
now I have said this before and will
continue to say it there are smart
Adventist Scholars out there folks
they're not all
stupid but getting these people to
engage is not as simple as snapping
one's fingers the point being we like to
interact with primary authoritative
Source documentation from the organ
ganization whether it be their
Publications Pioneers pastors and
Scholars
but tonight is going to be
anomalous tonight we're going to be
interacting with a group that wishes
they were a part of that club um they
want to act like they are thinking that
they are launching theological missiles
with the big boys only they are holding
spiritual squirt guns in their own
backyards shooting spitballs across the
fence tonight was supposed to be an
informal debate SL discussion between a
Seventh Day Adventist that reached out
and had some objections to some things
that were said by Sam Shimon the last
time that he was with us specifically
regarding Jesus being Michael the
Archangel this changed when he was
apparently contacted by a guy named
Edwin Cado who is one of these critics
of Christianity that wields one of these
spiritual squirt guns he claimed this
debate was a setup a setup and we've
done this before apparently referring to
these Adventists that have come on to
the uh platform here as
victims
victims yes victims we've apparently
victimized Adventists who of their own
valtion contacted us to come on here
nevertheless since the circus is back to
their standard ways of lying and making
up stories before we get into it I need
to connect some dots for you all as to
why tonight's stream is happening when
we are so used to listening to more more
serious-minded SDA individuals all right
so first
starters in a community post that these
guys made after this current stream was
scheduled their panties gotten a wad and
they wrote out this long dissertation
based on a few sentences as you'll see
in the video description of the stream
notice they write now miles at answering
adventism pretends he's innocent of
seeking us out notice this comment on
his so-called upcoming response to the
league oh how cool and here's what I and
you'll see it down in the description
Sam Shimon was originally originally
slated to be here for a debate with an
Adventist that demanded he be engaged
regarding Michael the Archangel this
gentleman backed out at the behest of
Edwin Cado from the official quote
unquote Advent Defense League claiming
that we quote like to get Christians who
aren't very knowledgeable to engage with
despite these individuals seeking us
out their response note the part that
reads despite these individuals seeking
us
out in other words we seek out less
knowledgeable individuals while accusing
them of seeking out less knowledgeable
individuals folks miles was the first to
seek out Edwin for a debate years ago
and Edwin merely followed up on that
original request until miles insisted he
won't do it because Edwin is basically a
meanie how ironic coming from a guy who
called Edwin an arrogant
prick uh yeah except my statement about
seeking us out folks was clearly about
the individuals that seek out
discussions with this
platform not me denying to have
solicited a debate with Edwin Cado
almost two years ago by these
individuals I was clearly referring back
to the part in quotes that I allegedly
like to get Christians which they mean
Adventists who aren't very knowledgeable
to come on here so that I can embarrass
them allegedly that's the
keyword and you all will see why this
was in quotes in a moment point being it
wasn't about these
guys but then we heard them once again
bring up that I wanted to debate Edwin
Cado almost two years ago I already
addressed this on our Channel where it
was demonstrated that their silly lie
that I'm scared to do so is exactly that
a silly lie but of course
as has been the running track
record they're still living in an
alternate reality because I didn't say I
was no longer interested in engaging
this guy because he's a meanie no I'm
not an
effeminate but once the I'm scared lie
was disproven now they've exchanged it
for a new one that Edwin's a meanie so I
won't debate him a poor
Edwin trying everything he can to
provoke one to
action for those that saw the entire
email thread which I showed in the video
I mentioned where I addressed all of
this I said he's ignored because he's an
arrogant pretentious nauseating jerk who
unlike myself doesn't say things to
people's
face AKA he's a coward which I also told
him in the email exchange not that he's
mean and unlike him I actually said what
I needed to directly to him on top of
this he publicly stated that he wants to
see me personally destroyed not just my
beliefs which I also showed the receipts
on he doesn't want me to come and see
that you know what they believe to be
the truth but he wants to see me
destroyed yeah no thanks coward I have
zero interest in engaging with people
who clearly are filled with hate and I
explained this in that video as well I
distinguish between individual 7th Day
Adventists no matter how much I disagree
with them and Seventh Day adventism
this guy does
not we want Adventist to come to know
the truth this guy wants to destroy
people so he can publicly feel like a
big shot and pound his chest ho ho ho
yeah come at me bro ho he's one of these
types and if you're a former Adventist
you know exactly the type I'm talking
about he has the Adventist Aura why
would I bother engaging with someone
like that move on
crybaby but again this is their typical
Mo and at this point I'm convinced isn't
possible for them to be truthful even
when the receipts are out there for
anyone to see they still lie to their
gullible listeners because they're
incapable of honesty even when
disagreeing with someone but now I'm
apparently denying that I sought to
debate this guy even though the video
explaining why he's ignored is on the
channel and I show the entire
conversation from the very beginning
where I solicited a debate with him yeah
makes total sense
but what's also fascinating about this
and I showed this in the video that I
just mentioned is that initially notice
what Edwin kado said to me when I first
reached out to him about
debating in part he says quote having
watched your last two debates it seems
to me you won't be able to act
professionally in a debate with me
constantly interrupting your opponent in
that manner and getting agitated to the
point of having to apologize to him will
only frustrate me and make me regret
agreeing to it among other things like
sucking your teeth rolling your eyes and
then trying to mask it all by saying
it's just that you're too
passionate ah so Mr kado was initially
unsure about debating me because of
what my
demeanor the same thing that led me to
realize this exact thing about him his
pretentious and hateful attitude was
enough to close that door dust my feet
off and move along and my you this was
also before answering adventism was
really up and going and like I stated or
rather showed the receipts on I told
this gentlemen you're free to come on to
one of our open mics that we have
because I'm not going to Bor you simply
because I'm not going to gatekeep like
that so if you want to engage come along
he denied that never wanted to show up
and instead they started doing all of
their own open mics and now I'm scared
because I won't show up to their goofy
platform yeah okay but this is another
example of the abject hypocrisy with
this indiv idual whines and cries about
my attitude saying he needs to pray
about even doing a debate because his
precious time is too valuable then he
gets mad when the same thing is said
back to him give me a break and now he's
gonna throw a tantrum like a crybaby to
try and get what he wants and demands
that we engage him holding his silly
streams where he summons people to come
before
him no
joke we're talking about a guy who
literally has streams where he demands
certain people show up he says they're
being summoned before him like he's a
monarch or something give me a break get
out of here you
goofball no one listens to your silly
[Laughter]
demands I summon you before me yeah kick
rocks you
loser pounding his chest like if I don't
show up I'm afraid of him but no no no
he's not pretentious or anything my
goodness man never mind back to their
Community post I continue secondly yeah
Edwin encouraged that young man not to
debate miles you have a problem with
that Miles he did that because the young
man admitted he's new to adventism and
not as knowledgeable but that did not
detour
you from trying to make a public
spectacle of
him we saw clearly the agenda to
embarrass him in the SDA church and took
immediate action to stop it no apologies
here then they move on to another part
of of the description from this video
where I said so instead since they fancy
themselves as high- hanging fruit we
will respond to their arguments in
response to claims Sam made regarding
what the Bible teaches about the nature
of death and the state of the Dead that
they allegedly easily refuted let's find
out to which they
respond the comment they fancy
themselves High hanging fruit is merely
his
opinion Edwin encouraged the young man
to back out not because we think we're
any better than him but because we know
exactly what miles was trying to do
since he's already done it
before miles simply didn't like a
snatching his victim out of his
hand well too bad miles but we'll do it
again and again along with more and more
responses to your
video I'm sorry
folks please keep
okay please keep in mind that ADL Works
in multiple ways to stop the lies of the
critics and win souls to the truth and
it's not only through video responses
what we did here is one of those other
ways along with giving personal studies
to people who have been confused and
discouraged by the critics this is a
solemn work and it will get done by
God's grace we will be watching and
responding to these so-called responses
to us if miles unblocks us we can
respond in the comment section as well
well we will see who has the truth see
you
there yeah so folks this gentleman
wasn't here to debate
me he was here to discuss with Sam as we
will see in a moment but
apparently I set up lowi information
Adventists and I'm on the prow to
embarrass them because I have an
agenda I apparently knew this guy was
new to adventism and I was trying to
victimize him allegedly key
word and these guys knew exactly what I
was up to apparently so they felt the
need to put their capes on and make sure
this didn't happen save a victim you
getting the Gotham City Vibes
here for anyone that's been riding with
us for a while you'll know how
ridiculous this silly narrative is the
idea that I'm out there looking for low
hanging fruit with an agenda to
embarrass them folks I've issued public
debate challenges to Doug Bachelor as
well as Martin Hannah Jan Pauline uh and
any of the scholars because I broadly
put this out there any of the scholars
at the Adventist biblical Research
Institute what's supposed to be the
highest theological body within the
organization the difference being I
don't run around and claim they're
scared of me because they haven't taken
me up on the challenge like we're in
sixth grade or something I mean there
could be multiple reasons that they
don't want to debate me and that's fine
but I don't exhibit crazy neurotic
obsessive ex-girlfriend syndrome and
constantly dwell on them and lie about
why they won't engage with me in hopes
that it provokes them to do
so it's like guys this bitter and
obsessed ex-girlfriend stick from him is
really getting old like move on buddy
move on so pathetic pitiful and cringe
it's like I'm just being honest it's
just like dude it is cringe it's kind of
creepy honestly move on move along it's
like on the one hand he claims I'm a
clueless ill-informed lwh hanging fruit
I know nothing about adventism he told
me years ago you're no different than
Steve Daly and EJ and Dale ratl and Dez
Ford oh I'm the same as all these other
people I'm clueless I know nothing about
adventism yet at the same time it's
become his life mission to debate me so
he can try and publicly destroy me and
feel good about destroying a clueless
ill and formed critic oh right the exact
thing he claims I Do by looking for lwi
information Adventist to
[Laughter]
embarass anyways that's where I stand I
want to engage with the foremost
theologically astute individuals this
organization has to offer Edwin Cado
does not fit the bill but let's look at
the whole exchange with this gentleman
that was supposed to be here tonight who
reached out to us and let's see how
accurate this assessment from the ADL is
here's the very first message and I
apologize for it being small I didn't
know a way to get it any bigger and I
didn't want to put it on individual
slides and people say you just made that
up no these are screenshots from where
he contacted
us I don't know this guy from Adam folks
he starts off he says Hey miles I'd love
to debate Jude 1 19 with you and Sam
shimone as well as second Thessalonians
4:16 care to have a discussion on those
verses Jesus is Michael the Archangel
and I saw your video on Jude 1 19 I
noticed you never bothered to address
the first portion of the verse where
Michael was disputing the body of Moses
and ignore how the beginning of the
verse explains the ending you guys also
conflate the Greek words Blasphemous
judgment and rebuking in Jude 1:9 when
those words have clear differences
according to the concordance furthermore
when you and Sam addressed 1
Thessalonians 4:16 for some reason you
guys set up a STW in SDA position to
attack the question is not whether
Angels were uh present at the
Resurrection the question is whose voice
raises the dead why did you guys not
address the SDA position by bringing up
John 529 through2 uh
25-29 which tells us the voice of Jesus
will raise the dead John 52-29 is a
parallel to 1 Thessalonians 4:16 and I'm
shocked you guys did not bother to bring
it up to which I simply replied with
what hi Caesar you're more than welcome
to come on to answering adventism and
bring your objections I will get Sam to
also come and I will neutrally moderate
so it isn't two
onone how soon would you like to come on
you'll be given equal time and
opportunity to
speak oh yeah I really had an agenda
right and this guy's supposedly a victim
someone who reaches out of their own
volition unprompted and is granted his
request yeah yet I supposedly sought to
take advantage of this guy by saying it
shouldn't be two onone and that I would
neutrally moderate to make sure the guy
had equal time to speak uninterrupted
not be railroaded and bring up his
objections to feel
heard oh no but these guys knew exactly
what was going on though right yeah good
one for those that aren't aware um you
might be shocked actually to to to hear
this some Adventists um they think
they've been given the spiritual gift of
omnition just in case you were wondering
but then I circled back around and said
I take that as a no because don't
typically schedule stuff on the Fly
especially this soon and I needed to get
it scheduled and set up ASAP if we were
going to do so to which he said and
responded sounds good when would be a
good time I don't reply right away
because I'm busy I can come on next week
how's that sound just curious though why
did you not bring up John 529 25-29 when
addressing 1 Thessalonians 4:16 since
that verse tells us who the voice of the
Archangel is I can save that question
for the debate if you would like I got
plenty of more questions by the way but
yeah let me know what time next week you
are available I would love to have a
discussion with you too that would be
great to which I responded by saying
what because we were utilizing Doug
bachelor's presentation and engaging
with what he brought up he didn't go
into John 5 but don't worry bring your
questions how is about Monday the 8th at
7 pm Central Standard Time as well as
again circling back on this we got to
get it on the content calendar ASAP if
we're going to do it again trying to
accommodate this guy because we don't
typically book stuff on the fly like
this he then asked that works great how
do I hop on the live sorry if I take
time to reply I just got off work and
have been busy but look forward to
talking with you on or talking to you on
Monday I then said I'll send you the
link the day of very easy if you can use
zoom you'll be able to use streamyard
which is what I use 700 p.m. CST on
Monday the 8th if you can hop on about 5
minutes early to test audio and video
that would be great looking forward to
it you'll have a five minute opening
before any open back and forth to
discuss your objections and challenges
walk through scripture Etc Monday at 7M
Central Standard Time please be on time
yeah real nefarious stuff right which
yielded this response that I shared in a
community post this past uh past
week hey miles I was looking forward to
debating you but I have a brother called
Edwin and kado and he recommended me not
to debate you he told me you like to get
Christians who are not very
knowledgeable to debate rather than
debating him or other sdas who know
scripture better than me and I admit I
do not know the writings of Ellen like
you or Edwin do I will study for a
couple years since I'm still new to SDA
teachings and we'll get back to you uh
then when I have learned more about the
teachings and I apologize miles God
bless ah so notice this is his first
mention of being new to
adventism his message that he was
bailing out but yeah I apparently knew
he was new to adventism and I was trying
to make a victim out of him and I had a
secret agenda to make him look
bad yeah and my final response was what
Caesar you reached out to us but all
right which is clearly why in the
description of this video the same claim
is in quotations referring to Edwin's
claim that we seek out unqualified
people with an agenda no these people
seek us out genius they reach out to us
of their own valtion and request to come
on I'm not out looking for people like
this and I've tried being courteous and
allowing them to come on which will no
longer happen and this is why it's like
you try and and accommodate and engage
with well-meaning people and have a good
dialogue and then cowards like this use
it to stir up drama using it as an
opportunity to pound their chest
publicly with their cape on claiming all
sorts of lies and falsities thinking
that they did something
Noble it's like we have tons of Sam's
listeners here tonight Sam has tons of
online discussions with people who
aren't very learned and he's patient
with them if they're sincere but these
guys knew there had to be some secret
attack plan because that's the world
they operate in so they project that on
to everyone else and since they operate
in a world of secret agendas and trying
to destroy people everyone else must be
also I then said there as you can see at
the end then have Edwin kado step in for
you since he apparently wants to put his
cape
on no the only people that had an agenda
was these guys who were obsessed with
answering adventism and think
everything's about
them and as is the running track record
they have no clue what they're talking
about folks this is the same crowd mind
you that came over into our live chat of
the video that necessitated silencing
their lie that I'm scared of them to
which Jason Thomas one of the
individuals you're going to have the
unfortunate uh experience of listening
to tonight he claimed I quit my job as
an Adventist Professor to do answering
adventism it's like they literally just
make stuff up about people and begin
spreading it and then we get to hear
about it from their gullible followers
that just pared it like
robots this is the same group of people
by the
way that are trying to buy
legitimacy by way of views and
subscribers because it's 2024 and they
probably aren't aware that anyone in in
marketing knows the tools to be able to
look at this
information since these guys want to
bark like dogs and my background is in
marketing notice what a normal growth
chart on YouTube looks like this is from
a social media Analytics tool I have
standard es and flows with a median
trajectory
upward this is what a natural YouTube
platform that's growing looks
like because folks YouTube is not Tik
Tok and Instagram especially right now
long form content is not
in people's attention spans are like
that of a goldfish un
unfortunately which is the proof that
answering adventism isn't in this for
the
money and here's what it looks like when
you purchase engagement like these guys
do and this is their
chart you go from virtually nothing with
no EB and flow to a massive Spike like
this years of virtually no engagement
followed by what's called statistical
anomaly especially for YouTube a massive
spike in this short window then the
sudden drop off when you stop paying
yeah nice try fellas been there done
that got the
T-shirt deceptively buying engagement to
pad your stats then asking people to
give you money based on that when the
numbers are all make
believe and since lying is second nature
to them of course they're going to lie
and project onto me that I'm lying I
made this up Etc but they know
they know and now they know that we all
know since they're watching right
now yeah you got busted fellas again
unserious and inauthentic individuals
anyone that reads growth charts for
social media knows what this is when
they see it I ran this by numerous
people in social media friends
acquaintances people I know that do
social media for a living for various
companies just to get their because I
already knew like I said but I I wanted
to just have a giggle so I showed them
this chart and I said what does this
look like to you every single one of
them purchasing engagement and they all
and a number of them said especially for
YouTube because it doesn't work that way
this a social media management 101 and
there's other metrics you can uh engage
to see this as well this is just one of
them and for Giggles I tracked their
data uh their data log one day for or a
couple days for 48 hours and I tracked
the bot activity so I've got all the
receipts so if they want to keep lying
and barking they will be further exposed
and we can dribble out more stuff like
this because I'm not playing games with
these
frauds let this be a Proverbs 1813
lesson if one gives an answer before he
hears it is folly and
shame I actually like the way that the
new living translates it I know it's a
paraphrase but it captures the point in
English well spouting off before
listening to the facts is both shameful
and foolish and this is why it is also
why they are largely ignored by this
platform they are not serious people
their theological prowess is abysmal as
we're about to very clearly see they lie
they slander they make stuff up they're
arrogant and pretentious they thrive on
drama and they lar online as some
official Adventist apologetics
organization that demands they be
engaged summons people in front of
them yeah and they want to be
acknowledged because they so desperately
want to be taken seriously in their shoe
box of a universe tonight is happening
because they wanted to put their cape on
and make up more stories about why
they're ignored 99% of the time and
since Sam was slated to be here
anyways we're going to listen to their
response to an old video of his on the
subject of the state of the Dead that
they claim that they easily refute
it and based on what you saw in that
intro clip buckle
up as always what's budy yeah thanks
again for being here and I apologize for
the long intro but these guys man are
just absolutely ridiculous yep I hope
the connection stays clear but by the
grace of the Lord Jesus Christ we ask
the Holy Spirit to fill us may the Holy
Spirit energize us to recall the
scriptures and interpret them correctly
destroy all a and sin and have his way
for the glory of the Father the Son the
Lord Jesus Almighty and the eternal
spirit the one true God in Jesus name so
yes just for the record I don't even
know these folks apart from you
mentioning them to me I haven't watched
their so-called response but if they're
this Brave and I hope they don't make
excuses how come they didn't join to try
to refute me and no another
thing as you just demonstrated you
proved it was that young man who asked
to debate me I didn't ask to debate them
right so I yeah going on right we have
an agenda we're trying to we're trying
to because they're they you've you
earned the title from them Sam you don't
know this but you've actually earned the
the badge of honor you're now considered
an Adventist critic that's the term they
use so so we like to call them uh
critics of Christianity because that's
what they are so well that's fine well
that's that's fine I don't live for
adventism I live for trying to proclaim
the truth of the Gospel of Jesus Christ
by the power of the holy spirit so when
someone tells me that Jesus is Archangel
Michael then obviously I'm going to
address that issue but there are a lot
of claims made in the beginning clip and
it was blasphemous in my opinion because
they don't know the Bible they don't
know christology so I wouldn't mind
demolishing their claims before we get
into the issue of death about Jesus
Christ a man on Earth and he wasn't
sustaining well hold on that's why they
bring it up we're going to listen to all
the fullness of those clips so we will
get to all that and we will absolutely
bury this heresy yeah want because I
don't want that I don't want that to go
untouched so I want to make all of that
was clipped from what we about to watch
okay and listen to and I haven't watched
so I'm just following your lead this is
going to be me hearing their responses
for the first time so I don't know what
they have to say apart from what you
played so let's go let's get into it
well before we start we need to look at
one statement from Ellen White regarding
the Adventist teaching on the nature of
the Soul so that you and the audience
understand why Adventists are so vem on
the subject okay so to start
this is from great controversy which she
claims in selected messages book three
page 122 paragraph 2 the words in this
book are allegedly barricaded by a thus
saith the Lord for those that are knew
the papal Tiara is photoshopped because
Ellen White is functionally the pope of
adventism notice what she says quote
through the two great errors the
immortality of the soul and Sunday
sacredness Satan will bring the people
under his deceptions while the former
lays the foundation of spiritualism the
latter creates a bond of sympathy with
Rome the Protestants of the United
States will be foremost in stretching
their hands across the gulf to grasp the
hand of spiritualism they will reach
over the abyss to clasp hands with the
Roman power and under the influence of
this three-fold Union this country will
follow in the steps of Rome in trampling
on the rights of conscience close quote
so according to her prophetic voice the
teaching of Sunday s ESS and the
classical Christian teaching on the soul
will allegedly be the two things that
bring about their end times hysteria
around Protestants and Catholics and I
use the phrase classical Christian
teaching for a reason because what they
claim christians mean by the term
immortality of the Soul such as irenaeus
example is not what Christians mean by
that
phrase but it was also these two
teachings Sunday sacredness and the
immortality of the soul that she claimed
to be shown in vision from God are
sending people to predition at lightning
speed as a deception of Satan
notice quote I saw vision from God the
rapidity with which this delusion was
spreading in part talking about the
state of the Dead the nature of the
Soul a train of cars was shown me going
with the speed of lightning the angel
bade me look carefully I fixed my eyes
upon the train it seemed that the whole
world was on
board that there could not be one left
said the angel they're binding in
bundles ready to burn then he showed me
the conductor who appeared like a
stately Fair person whom all the
passengers looked up to and reverenced I
was perplexed and asked my attending
Angel who it
was he said it is Satan he's the
conductor in the form of an angel of
Light he's taken the world captive
they're giving o uh they given over to
strong delusions to believe a lie that
they may be
damned this agent the next highest in
order to him is the engineer and other
of his agents are employed in different
offices as he may need them and they are
all going with lightning speed to
predition close
quote so those of us that don't believe
like Adventists do about the soul are
deceived by Satan and we are on the
proverbial train headed to hell for
believing a deception supposedly because
God showed this to Ellen White in a
vision the point being Adventists are
taught that one of the chief deceptions
of Satan is what Christians historically
believe about the soul and this is the
context in which their fervor around the
subject stems from Christians have to
understand that so with that as the
backdrop let's get into it so you know
how it goes I'm going to play the video
as soon as you hear something that
sounds off let's talk about it God does
not die Jesus die how can he be God and
if he's God who died who is running the
universe do you understand the
objection okay if you understand the
objection let's answer it un understand
what the Assumption of the objection is
the
Assumption of the
objection is that death means ceasing to
exist ceasing to be conscious secession
of Life although there are groups like
seven-day Adventists that believe that
this is not a Biblical teaching because
understand what the objection implies
if Jesus Is God and he died then who is
running the universe assumption
implication for Jesus to die he must
have cease to
exist and if he sees to exist then he's
not running the universe and God never
sees us to exist but you understand the
objection right because we need to
answer
this so let's talk about that there were
two things that he brought up he says um
you know did Jesus die if he died that
means he SE ceases to exist and I guess
he's bring that off of how we view the
state of the Dead um and so if if Jesus
truly did die then who's running the
universe so I think there's two
questions we need to answer did Jesus
truly
die let's see what the Bible says about
that can we go to um Isaiah CH uh
chapter 53 verse
10 let's do
it what does Isaiah 53:10 say about the
death of Jesus it says yet it pleased
the Lord to bruise him he hath put him
to grief when thou shalt make his what
soul his soul Thou shalt make his soul a
an offering for sin he shall see his
seed he shall prolong his days and the
pleasure of the Lord shall prosper in
his hand so according to this verse what
was a sin
offering it says his soul his soul was a
sin offering what does that word soul
mean in the
concordance let's check it
out H
5315 it is the word uh
nefesh it means Soul you want me to go
to strongs or go to
strongs all right a breathing creature
that is an animal I don't know m i mean
the way that I like to look at it is I
see that it means Soul 416 times but
there's also other ways that that word
is being used it also means life his
life Souls lives person the person
itself the heart the mind yeah himself
creature body so yeah but there two main
uh definitions of the word is soul or
the life itself right the person yeah so
we understand that the the soul or the
life of Jesus was made a sin offering
now what does it mean that it was a sin
offering do we know what happened to all
sin offerings in scripture what does
Leviticus chapter 14 verse 13
say and he shall slay the lamb in the
place where he shall kill the sin
offering and the burnt offering in the
Holy place for as the sin offering is
the priest so is the trespass offering
it is most holy all sin offerings in
scripture were killed what does that say
about the life of Jesus did Jesus really
died if he was a sin offering yes he
absolutely did that's what the Bible
says now the Bible also goes on to say
in um Revelation chap 1 verse 18 can we
turn there Revelation chap 1 verse
18 it says I am he that liveth and was
dead and behold I am alive forever more
amen and have the keys to hell and of
death so notice Jesus says that I am
alive forever more right now if Jesus
wasn't truly dead if his soul wasn't
truly dead why would he be saying that I
am now alive forever more if he was
never truly dead does that make sense
Jesus had to have truly died he had to
have been dead right and it also said
that he was dead meaning that at one
point Jesus did die and he rose again
from the
grave all right so
Sam I I warned you they are going to do
Hopscotch ex aesus jumping all over the
Bible so we will take it a few verses at
a time you're also getting to see them
put to use William Miller's principles
of Bible interpretation where they claim
all all you need is a Bible and a
concordance and now you basically know
Greek and Hebrew but for starters it
doesn't sound like these guys even
understand the objection in the clip
they played because they focused on
arguing that the Bible says Jesus died
which no duh Christians affirm the
Apostles Creed as if this audience even
needs to see this I mean from the second
Stan a Christian what do we believe we
believe in Jesus Christ his only son our
Lord who was conceived by the Holy
Spirit born of the Virgin Mary suffered
under pontious Pilate was
crucified died and was buried he
descended to Hell the third day he rose
again from the dead he ascended to
heaven and is seated at the right hand
of God the Father Almighty from there he
will come to judge the living and the
dead the problem that Sam mentioned was
the faulty
assumptions Adventists make about the
word death not whether or not Jesus died
there was no addressing this only
question begging they simply continued
assuming what needed to be demonstrated
by pointing to proof texts that say
Jesus died and then porting into there
the SDA understanding of death but Sam
Isaiah 53:10 Leviticus 14 and Revelation
1:18 prove the Adventist understanding
of death and the Soul because they say
Jesus's Soul was offered up and that all
sin offerings were killed they silenced
you right oh yeah they they destroyed me
anyway I I don't know how you deal with
this and how you can be patient with
this because it's nonsense it's garbage
and this is why they won't debate number
one no one denied that Jesus died so I
don't know what they're getting at but
now I want you guys to see the blasphemy
because they're trying to say that if
Jesus offered his soul that means his
soul died so that his soul ceased to be
so God ceased to be they didn't address
the objection my objection was if Jesus
Is God In the Flesh and Jesus is ever
living as God because God cannot see to
be conscious he cannot cease to
consciously exist if we Define death as
me secession of life because they're
saying see he offered his soul so he
ceased to be well that means god ceased
to be and so they're back to the
original objection which they did not
address so now I want you guys because
you're live you didn't have the courage
to come here and debate me I want you to
tell everyone that you believe Jesus the
God man ceased to be consciously
so that God the son cease to exist and
how can God the son cease to exist if
you believe he's the second person of
the Trinity equal to the father and the
spirit now brother you don't need to put
me full screen you can be alongside of
me work together so notice they didn't
address the objection the objection was
if Jesus Is God and God is ever living
and doesn't cease to exist so if Jesus
died and he ceased to exist how can he
be God so now guys I want you to catch
the blasphemy see they're not Christians
they're Heretics they just said Jesus
ceased to exist now unless they want to
claim he wasn't God on Earth that's
another blasphemy because then they're
saying he was no longer God but only a
man so what happened to divine nature
and I hope they don't butcher
Philippians 2 because I'm going to
butcher their butchering Philippians 2
but we'll get there I'm G to butcher the
butchering Philippians too are
you well not only are they but wait
until we look at uh some of the sources
that we're going to look at from the SDA
church and their utilization of
Philippians 2 and I'll be really really
curious to see these apologists deal
with these claims and they have to do
ironically enough with Sam Michael but
deont go ahead go ahead you're were
saying go ahead because I want I was
gonna say Deontay is actually wrong
because not all sin offerings were
killed and this is their Achilles heel
the scapegoat was a part of the singular
sin offering Leviticus 165 and it was
not killed now Adventists will twist and
do all sorts of mental gymnastics to try
and get around this but the text is
clear Two Goats One Singular sin
offering so he's not even right on that
tertiary Point yep yep now I I wonder if
they assume they he'll eventually die
because he's being L off into the
Wilderness so they'll die but put that
aside let's put this aside now they
again assume that if he offered his soul
and a soul died that means the soul
ceased to exist but that's begging the
question guys try a little harder you're
assuming your definition of death that
if you die you cease to exist I'm about
to now bury that definition because if
you don't mind brother open up John
29-22 and since he went to Revelation
now watch what they're going to do
because they themselves acknowledged
that even the lexican will affirm that
the term nephesh or if you want to go
with the Greek
term or Psy the term for soul
has a broad range of meaning so you have
to determine the precise meaning
depending on the context how a word is
used in context but that Jesus is
offering his soul doesn't mean he ceased
to exist yes his soul died he offered
his soul unto death but what does death
mean so quoting versus to show that he
offered his soul and that means he
ceased to exist begs a question you have
prove in your case and then we're going
to look at passages where people are
dead but they're said to still be alive
as conscious Souls but you're G to
explain that away oh it's a vision it's
apocalyptic imagery but you quoted
Revelation one you can't have your cake
in needed to if a book is good enough to
prove your point then it's good enough
to demolish your point but we're going
to demonstrate that slowly read for me
John 219 and 22 yep Jesus answered them
destroy this Temple and in three days I
will raise raise it up the Jews then
said it's taken 4 to six years to build
this Temple and you'll raise it up in 3
days but he was speaking about the
Temple of his body when therefore he was
raised from the dead his disciples
remembered that he had said this and
they believed the scripture and the word
that Jesus had spoken so now I'm a
little confused because they're trying
to prove that Jesus's Soul died which
means he ceased to exist then how could
Christ personally
I will raise it up how could he have
personally raised his body back to life
if he wasn't still consciously existing
that was my argument what was my
argument let's see if you can actually
address it in real time because you
can't do it here because you're too
afraid because you'll be demolished for
your butchering of scripture may the
Lord have mercy on you and you repent
and leave LG white this tool of
Satan notice again no one denies that
Jesus offered his soul in fact give you
one in the Greek in Mark 10:45 there
Jesus says Mark you don't need to turn
there Mark 10:45 he says for even the
son of man did not come to be
served but to serve and offer his soul
if you look at the word Greek word Su or
Psy or get psychology as a ransom for
many okay Jesus offered his
soul and he died and his soul died what
does that mean it it doesn't mean he
ceased to exist because here the Lord
says he personally will raise his body
back to life notice again destroy this
Temple destroy my body and I'll raise my
body back to life so that didn't help
you in the least but it did show you
guys are blasphemers it demonstrated
you're Heretics because guys I want
everyone here and clip it they just said
that Jesus as God who became flesh
ceased to exist so now either they're
going to have to admit God can cease to
exist which then destroys the very
definition of God because he's a
necessary being whoever Lives who never
dies meaning cease to exist in their
definition or they're going to have to
then argue the other Blasphemous
assertion that he ceased to be God while
he became man well what happened to
Divine Nature where did it go either way
you guys are blasphemers but let's let's
make it harder for them there are places
in which clearly the soul is
distinguished from the body so that you
can kill the body but not kill the soul
can you read Matthew 10:28 for us yep
the words of Our Lord yeah one of the
strongest dichotomies in scripture which
completely butchers yeah before you read
I want people to know this is what
they're calling they're committing a
root fallacy eological fallacy they're
seeing how a word is used predominant or
they see what the word originally meant
and assume that this meaning must have
be applied in every sense well that's
going to bury them because now Matthew
10:28 it is not loading here all right
there we
go all
right so Jesus says and do not fear
Those Who Kill the body but cannot kill
the soul rather fear Him who can destroy
both soul and Body in Hell see they just
buried themselves again because notice
what they said that when Jesus offered
his soul that means he died well how did
he offer his soul well he died in the
flesh in the body and the cross so that
means if you kill the body you kill the
soul right that's their argument now
they're gonna go ahead well I was just
gonna say because for those that don't
know Soul sleep is not the most accurate
term for their position I call it Soul
death because what they claim is that
the soul is the equivalent of an an
analogy I used to hear when I was
growing up in adventism was if you had a
pile of nails and a pile of board you
have a pile of nails and a pile of
boards if you put the two together you
get a box but if you take them apart the
Box no longer exist they claim the soul
is like the Box the body and breath come
together to create the soul if you
separate the two the soul no longer
exists but as you can see here Jesus
clearly says that the body can die and
the soul is not dead exactly so when
they kill Jesus's body if we follow our
Lord's words then his soul did not cease
to exist so yes the soul dies without
ceasing to exist this is what they're
not getting they're assuming if you die
you cease to exist no so the Lord
offered his soul in death and yet he
didn't cease to exist because death is
the moment when the soul or Spirit
leaves your body which is why your body
is no longer animated so that's Matthew
10:28 but let's look at other ver now
remember they went to Revelation right
yep now guys how much how many of you
want to bet me and I'm not a betting man
I believe gambling can is sinful or can
be sinful I know but how many of you
want to bet me that they're going to say
well this is apocalyptic imagery it's
symbolism you can't take it literally
and yet they're the ones who appeal to
Revelation can you read only when it's
convenient only when it's convenient
because they'll tell you for example one
of the supports that they'll try and
tell you for there being a literal
physical temple building in heaven that
Jesus is conducting the investigative
judgment in yada yada well Revelation
one apocalyptic symbolism huh Revelation
1 says that he's amongst the
candlesticks the lampstands even though
Revelation 120 says the lampstands are
churches seven churches y oh oh oh so so
that's not that's not apocalyptic
simplism Now watch how they're gonna
explain this away Revelation 69 to11 and
notice conveniently they use the word
Soul there the Greek word for soul Su
but what does it
say sorry it's taking a minute to load
here and I don't know exactly why these
are very pathetically bad no wonder they
don't debate I don't blame you guys if
these are your arguments I would stay in
your own corner and hide behind your
YouTube channel because that's the best
you got but anyway Revelation 69 it's
gonna get worse it's gonna get a lot
worse brother honestly just listening
for a few minutes it agitates my spirit
May the spirit give us perfect self-
constraint and fill us with joy to
demolish our blasphemies because I can't
handle Bible butcher who blashe the Lord
but for the sake of the Lord we'll do it
to their objections Revelation 69
to1 when he opened the fifth seal I saw
under the altar The Souls of those who
had been slain for the word of God and
for the witness they had born what did
he see The Souls of those
slain oh but I thought if you get
slain that means not only your body but
your soul because somehow you are your
soul your soul is you so if I Slaughter
your body I'm slaughtering you and
therefore I'm slaughtering your soul and
that means you don't exist right yeah
because if your breath separates from
your body your soul no longer exists but
how can they be so oh but it's
apocalyptic here it's not literal see
it's their IPs Dix it it's you know we
don't take it literally therefore it
can't be literal but this part we say
it's literal yeah how convenient but I'm
going to show you not only apocalyptic
literature I'm going to show you other
places where physical death is where the
Soul and Spirit leave and you cannot
explain this way as apocalyptic
symbolism so reread that Revelation
6:9-11 when he opened the fifth seal I
saw under the altar The Souls of those
who had been slain for the word of God
and for the witness they had borne they
cried out with a loud voice oh Sovereign
Lord holy and true how long before you
will judge and avenge our blood on those
who dwell on the
earth then they were each given a white
robe and told to rest a little longer
until the number of their fellow
servants and their brothers should be
complete
who were to be killed as they
themselves had
been so let me get this
straight the Lord is telling them he
will avenge their blood as soon as the
full number of the martyrs is
complete that's what it says right there
that's correct so in other
words just like we know there will be
Christians who will be literally killed
on earth and the Lord knows the number
of those who will be killed and once
that number is complete then will avenge
them and just like we know the Lord will
literally come to judge a living and the
dead why would I then allegorize that
these are literal Souls who are there
being comforted and wearing white robes
why would I allegorize that if the Lord
judging the inhabitants of the Earth for
slaying his servants is not allegorical
it's literal and if Christians being
killed on Earth is not allegorical but
literal why then would I assume that the
souls who are consciously alive after
they were slain that's not literal
that's allegorical
can you explain that to me
no but let me prove to you that these
Souls who are slain right whom the Lord
will avenge it's not allegorical now
remember why I'm saying it's not
allegorical folks because the element of
the Lord judging the inham of the Earth
for slaying Christians that's actual no
one's going to allegorize that unless
they're full predis who don't believe
Jesus will return physically bod which
is another damnable heresy and
Christians being Slaughter on Earth
that's literal that's not
allegorical so then the souls who are
now alive after being slain why would I
allegorize that and why would I assume
that they're not consciously alive and
why are they under the alter by the way
which now actually goes back to his
point see when they make that argument
they bury themselves because they
believe there's a Heavenly Tabernacle
right absolutely and they believe just
like what just like what was on Earth
only what was on Earth is a scaled down
replica of that true Heavenly sanctuary
building and it has a holy Place
apartment and a Most Holy Place
apartment and an 1844 Jesus got up off
of a throne in the Holy Place apartment
moving to the most holy place okay so
there's an literal
altar a literal Tabernacle a literal
Throne Mercy Seat well you know why
they're before the altar gentlemen
because when they were slaughtered on
Earth God accepted their deaths as a
pleasing sacrifice being presented
before the altar you guys you just
buried yourselves because you use Isaiah
53:10 that the Lord offered his soul as
an asham a guilt offering and yet here
we have souls who were sacrificed
without ceasing to exist and their souls
are now before the altar as that
acceptable sacrifice which shows your
definition of
Soul death is unbiblical you see what
you guys did to
yourselves you see that right brother
yeah and not just that but this is
another case of them doing what's called
illegitimate totality transfer where
they just Port into the meaning of a
word that it always essentially means
the same thing across the board and then
whenever they see that word they just
assume that
understanding or they'll go to the the
concordance and the concordance is
apparently the infallible guide for them
yeah exactly not LG white but or LG
white and concordance if agrees with LG
white they're false prophets
now let me show you other examples where
physical death occurs because your soul
leaves or your spirit leaves showing
that the soul and the body are not
always identical now let me
repeat words have broad range of meaning
yeah the specific meaning of the
word has to be determined by the context
at times Soul refers to you just you
bless the Lord oh my soul meaning I Will
Bless The Lord some sometimes it refers
to the seat of
emotion sometimes it refers to that
non-physical aspect of you that is
animating your body and when it leaves
your body ceases to be living now I'm
going to show you that can you read for
me James
2:26 yep we're gonna now use Soul and
Spirit because there are times in which
Soul Spirit are used interchangeably
synonymously NE
ORS they're used sometimes
interchangeably synonymously and some
people think they're three aspects to us
Soul spirit and body well whatever I'm
not here to debate that point if you're
a trotus or a dichotomus but James 226
what does it say for as the body apart
from the spirit is dead so also Faith
apart from works is dead now they
believe works are are distinct from
Faith right correct so they have to
admit the spirit is distinct from the
body right
well if you were using logic but again
this this doesn't tend to be the Forte
of of this crowd but how they going to
get around it if they're going to tell
me yeah works are not identical to Faith
they're distinguished but they're in
seum that you can have saving faith if
it doesn't Encompass works then how are
you GNA tell me the spirit is not
distinct from the body which is why you
can't separate the spirit of the body
because if the spirit leaves the body
then the body dies
right correct so there you go that's
their
claim no but the spirit to them cannot
be distinct from the body in the sense
that if you're telling me all I am
because when they say I'm a soul now
would they Define Soul different from
Spirit yeah so it depends now when you
actually deal with people that are
actually um like I said reputable in
this organization not these these guys
um you will find that they will say it
does depend on the context but they
often times say the spirit is the breath
of a man um God God breathed into man
the the breath of life and so the spirit
is the let me correct them on that now
let me correct okay go ahead I want to
correct the error now they're playing
games because it doesn't say he breathed
Rach into them in Genesis 2:7 it says
when he breathed the breath of life and
Man became a living Soul it's not the
word spirit so are they now saying Soul
and Spirit are interchangeable because
that's going to bury them further well
like I said I don't know about these
guys specifically um but it if you look
at the abous belief fundamental beliefs
book I've cited that periodically when
you've been on here it's the exposition
of their own beliefs they have a whole
section in there where they talk about
the difference between the spirit and
the soul and the body and what being a
living Soul means so they will typically
distinguish between spirit and soul okay
well that's my point if they go to
Genesis 27 that doesn't use the word r
it doesn't use the word r which is
Spirit if if you actually look at it if
you bring up the concordance when it
says and yahwah God Yahweh God formed a
man from the dust of the ground and
breathed into him the breath of life and
Man became a living
Soul y it says soul and he breathed the
breath of life it doesn't say breathed
the breath of spirit there so if they're
going to say that's the spirit being
infused well they just argued spirit and
soul are interchangeable so then if the
soul if the body dies mean the soul dies
then that means the body dies the spirit
dies but here we're told no the spirit
leaves and the body dies and to show you
that the spirit still consciously exists
when it leaves the body now let's go to
another reference Hebrews 12:22 to 24 y
Heavenly Mount Zion yep Hebrews 12:22 to
24 here is proof that when your body
dies it's because your spirit leaves but
your spirit is still ious and Alive
Hebrews 1222
to4 sorry guys it's take me it only it
takes a few minutes to spouse error like
these Heretics but it takes a long time
to refute it so I'm going slowly because
I didn't listen to it I wouldn't listen
to it they waste my time but I'm doing
it for the benefit of you guys and by
the power of the Holy Spirit giving us
recall scripture May Empower us to
execute it correctly they're Heretics
they're not Christians because they're
going to end up blaspheming the Lord and
I sense it because they're going to end
up having say Jesus wasn't God on Earth
blasphemy it's going to get it's going
to get a lot worse a lot worse here's
the proof that when your spirit leaves
your body your body returns us but your
spirit is still alive here Hebrews 12:22
to
24 but you have come to Mount Zion and
to the city of the Living God the
heavenly Jerusalem and to innumerable
angels of fesal gathering and to the
assembly of the firstborn who are
enrolled in heaven and to God the judge
of all and to the spirits of the
righteous made perfect who what what's
there the spirits of the righteous made
perfect where are their
bodies in the grave so but their Spirits
are not dead in the definition their
espousing their Spirits are there so let
me ask you a question before they tap
Dan around
this they believe in the Heavenly
Jerusalem right correct and they believe
God the father is there right correct
and the angels are there right
correct so when it says you've come to
Mount Zion Heavenly Jerusalem city of
living God to numerable Angels that's
literal right correct and God the judge
of all he's literally there correct then
why would you allegorize that the
spirits of just men made perfect are
there how you going to allegorize that
if you're going to take Heavenly
Jerusalem as being actual and you're
going to take angels as actually living
there there actually there it's literal
and God the father is literally there
and then he going to talk about Jesus
Christ the mede of a New Covenant he's
also literally there and the blood he
presents which they would take literally
then how the hell are you going to get
around the fact that the spirits of
these men are also literally there and
they're alive and they're having church
because it says the Church of the
firstborn those who first fruits of the
Believers who are now having Church in
heaven how do you going to get around
that one yeah that they won't and this
is also why they're not sometimes you'll
get Adventists that tell you no no no we
don't necessarily officially affirm the
Creeds but in substance we would agree
with with what's there no you wouldn't
because you don't believe there's a
church in heaven right now that gathers
alongside the body on Earth and worships
with us that's right there I mean it
says it says because the word assembly
is the word for church correct assembly
and church I should say assembly and
Church of the firstborn who are
registered in heaven so folks you keep
bearing yourselves because you believe
Angels literally are in heaven there's a
literal Heavenly Jerusalem God the
father is literally there Christ is
literally there presenting his blood
that means the spirits of these men must
also literally be there showing that
it's when your spirit leaves your body
your body dies but your spirit is still
conscious and
Alive now you can finish it reread 23 to
24 because I got a few more and then we
can move on but I just want to make this
point clear and to the assembly of the
firstborn who are enrolled in heaven and
to God the judge of all and to the
spirits of the righteous made perfect
and to Jesus the mediator of a New
Covenant and to the sprinkled blood that
speaks a better word than the blood of
Abel yep now what that means is it's a
it's a referencing Genesis 4:10 let me
explain the last part when Cain tried to
cover his sin by saying when God ask him
where is your brother he goes how do I
know my My Brother's Keeper God then
said what have you done the Bloods of
your brother cries out to me meaning
I've seen his blood because you've
murdered him and his blood cries out to
me meaning by seeing the blood that you
shed it calls for judgment whereas the
blood of Christ speaks a better word and
that the blood of Christ calls for
reconciliation not judgment and wrath
but so now you got
problems Adventist group because you
cannot allegorize the Spirits in heaven
saying well that's allegorical nor can
you do it for the souls in Revelation
6911 so notice one place it says they're
there as Souls the martyrs here it says
they're there as Spirits what's missing
their bodies because when they were
slain on Earth their bodies returned to
the dust but their souls and Spirits
left now let me give you a few more and
I don't know because do they well anyway
we'll see let's let's go to again I'm
going to same same them Luke 9 54 I'm
sorry Luke 8
54-55 when gyrus his daughter died why
did she die and how was she revived Luke
8 5455 now remember this is the reversal
of James 226 when he goes to Luke 8 5455
I want you guys to pay attention James
226 says just as the body without the
spirit is dead so the spirit leaves your
body dies well what happens if your
spirit returns to your body you live and
then I'm going to give you a couple more
now read Luke 8545
this is the reversal of James
2:26 but taking her by the hand he
called saying child arise and her spirit
returned and she got up at once and he
directed that something should be given
her to eat so why did her body come to
life because the spirit entered her body
yeah but Sam that's the breath that's
the Breath of Life returning into the
body that's why it's not that the spirit
was animate
so the Breath of Life returned to her
body so the breath of life left the body
in James 226 which is why death occurred
and the Breath of Life are now in heaven
consciously having fellowship with
angels and God in Christ yeah okay I'm
convinced yep but you understand James
2:26 says death occurs when the spirit
leaves the body which means if the
spirit enters the body then your body is
now animated right correct and that's
what we saw here here her spirit
returned to to her body correct because
that's why she died her spirit left her
body so at least we're establishing the
spirit and the body are not identical
the soul and the body are not always
used synonymously there are times in
which the soul is not the body so you
can kill the B body and do nothing to
the soul and then the spirit continues
to exist apart from the body as we've
demonstrated now go to 2 Corinthians 12
verses 2 to
4 2 Corinthians 12 2-4 because here I
don't know what they're going to do with
this one because they cannot deny that
this is a revelation that was given to a
man 14 years prior to the time that Paul
wrote 2 Corinthians 12 and the context
shows Paul is referring to himself but
be that as it may notice what he says
here Paul writes I Know a Man in Christ
who 14 years ago was caught up to the
third heaven whether in the body or out
of the body I wait wait you confused me
how can someone be caught up to heaven
without the body because he says that's
possible I don't know if it's out of the
body he left his body or he was taken in
his body how does that make sense in
light of their view because if you're
out of your body how do you continue to
experience Consciousness according to
them uh the same problem here uh that we
see in Philippians 1 where Paul says his
desire is to depart from his body and be
with the Lord but he knows that for the
sake of the church the the body of
Christ he remains in his body for a
little while longer um apparently
according to them Paul desired to cease
to exist and his breath to go back to
God and his body to go back to the
ground but it can't mean that because it
says this person whether in the body a
of the body saw the third heaven saw
paradise and was given Mysteries that
could not be uttered correct reread it
right second it's just a vision though
Sam it's just a vision I'm glad is that
one of their objections because now I'm
going to destroy that argument depends
who you talk to I can't speak for those
guys I don't know it wouldn't surprise
me if they it wouldn't surprise me if
they've used that but I've heard that
from Adventist well brother I'm GNA bury
that argument because that shows you
they don't know what a vision means I
GNA bury that I'm glad you brought it up
guys because I well it's a vision well
I'm going to show you you don't know
what Visions mean because if you take
your definition of vision in the sense
that you want to that well it's a vision
so we can't take it literally man that
means Paul did not literally see Jesus
because in Acts 26:19 he says he did not
prove unfaithful to the vision and he's
talking about the vision where he saw
there isn't Christ so that means he
didn't see Christ because it was a
vision and he wasn't and he wasn't an
apostle then exactly but we'll get there
because that's part of being an apostle
yep now yeah we'll get to that one but I
want you to read for me again 2
Corinthians 122 to4 okay I Know a Man in
Christ who 14 years ago was caught up to
the third heaven whether in the body or
out of the body I do not know God knows
and I know that this man was caught up
into
Paradise whether in the body or out of
the body I do not know God knows and he
heard things that cannot be told which
man may not utter okay now miles I'm
confused if out of the body means he
ceased to exist because his breath left
how does someone who is no longer
consciously existing hear and see things
that are
inexpressible well right that when you
use logic that that becomes a a problem
but again the these individuals that
we're dealing with here
um that they don't tend to employ that
so now let me turn the vision argument
let me beat them at their own game and
already refute their argument if they
use that in their life oh well Vision
doesn't mean it's literal okay because
in Matthew 17 I want you to open up I'm
going to show you how to destroy this
objection because I hear all the time
and I get sick of it because that shows
you they don't understand what Vision
means and doesn't mean biblically so if
you go to Matthew 17 you know what I'm
going to refer to but if you read the
first five verses Jesus is transfigured
do they believe that
literally um yeah and I point this out
all the time because they will often try
and oftentimes try to use it's funny
they'll play both sides of the fence
sometimes on this Adventist will I don't
know about these guys but Adventist will
sometimes play both sides of the field
on this and I always point to here to
say that uh the Transfiguration is said
to be a vision yet what they
experienced was real it was literal it
wasn't just like uh you know often times
what what people visualize when they
think of a vision you got it so you
anticipated it so Jesus is transfigured
James Peter and John see it but it's
called The Vision so he didn't really he
wasn't really transfigured then they saw
a cloud come down and a voice from the
cloud saying this is my beloved
Son my son of my love listen to him they
didn't literally hear a voice well Peter
says they did I'll get there but but
then you got the problem because in
Matthew 1773 it says Moses and Elijah
appeared how did they
appear how did Moses and Elijah appear
because according to them death means
ceasing to exist are you going to tell
me well that's not literal so Jesus
being transfigured is not literal the
cloud coming down them in verse five is
not literal them hearing God's voice
audibly say this is my son whom I love
listen to him is not literal of course
it's literal so then why would you argue
that Moses Elijah did not actually
appear so they're actually consciously
alive they didn't cease to exist albeit
without their bodies now to show you
that Peter himself says this actually
happened we actually heard the voice of
God we actually saw Jesus glorified
which means they actually saw Moses and
Elijah besides the fact in verse four he
says let me build three shelters one for
you and Moses Elijah why would you want
shelters if you're not actually seeing
Moses and Elijah appearing in their
spiritual forms but let's see what he
says in second Peter
11618 real quick and I will read this um
I will say when it comes to official
Adventist representation by way of
sources Etc they don't make this silly
claim or or argument um but varying
Adventists out there sometimes will
because they'll claim like you were here
last time and you saw they claim that
Michael the Archangel resurrected Moses
and took him to Heaven remember Ellen
White showed us that and so because
that's the case that's how Moses was
able to be there at the Transfiguration
was because Michael the Archangel came
down and resurrected him so again the
official position of the organization is
not going to make this argument but lots
of individual Adventists will and these
guys it wouldn't surprise me if they
make this horrible argument and let me
ref let me refute that show me a single
passage where it says Moses was
resurrected well right and we and we got
into that folks you can go check that
out in the last stream we went really in
depth on that and showed the
Ridiculousness of this because they try
to use this for support of Jesus being
Michael the Archangel and we are going
to get to a segment ironically enough
when they talk about Philippians 2 where
we are going to bring up Michael so
maybe we save that for there okay we'll
do but what I want you to do just for to
show that Peter took this to be
something actually seen second Peter 116
because I want to now refute what a
vision is and isn't because they're
gonna say well it's a vision because I'm
gonna now refute that second Peter 1618
okay sorry guys we're belaboring this
point it's was going to take time so if
you have to do a part two or go I don't
mind but I I just like I said it's easy
to spew heresies it takes longer to
demolish them thoroughly and I'm going
to demolish them thoroughly by the grace
of Jesus Christ so in second Peter 11618
does Peter confirm they saw Christ
actually glorified and heard an actual
voice glorifying Christ because he's
referring to the Mount of
transfiguration y for we did not follow
cleverly devised myths when we made
known to you the power and coming of our
Lord Jesus Christ but we were
eyewitnesses of his majesty for when he
received honor and Glory from God the
father and the voice was born to him by
the Majestic Glory this is my beloved
Son with whom I'm well pleased we
ourselves heard this very voice born
from heaven and we were with him on the
Holy Mountain so he actually heard an
actual voice saw Christ actually
glorified on an actual mountain right
correct but Matthew said
179 it's called a vision Jesus said tell
no man the vision until the son of man
is raised can you show that Matthew 179
correct so a vision doesn't mean you're
not seeing real things and even if it's
symbolic it's a symbol of something real
Matthew
179 and as they were coming down the
mountain Jesus commanded them tell no
one the vision until the son of man is
raised from the dead now let me give you
another vision that has to be real
meaning even though it's called a vision
doesn't mean you're not seeing reality
as it is even a symbol is pointing to
reality so you're going to have to then
decipher the symbol go to acts 265
to19 okay I'm gonna go off camera just
for a second it's fine okay acts 2615
to19 watch here
okay one second it's I think it's
something with Bible Gateway this
evening it's not working we no rush if
you need to do something else go
ahead now this is Paul recounting his
encounter when he he saw and he was
converted now watch what he's gonna say
and I said who are you Lord and the Lord
said I am Jesus whom you are persecuting
but rise and stand upon your feet for I
have appeared to you for this purpose to
appoint you as a servant and witness to
the things in which you have seen me and
to those in which I will appear to you
now notice what he says brother he saysi
have appeared to you so he actually
appeared to him right correct and I'll
appear to you again in the future but
now watch though keep reading delivering
you from your people and from the
Gentiles to whom I am sending you to
open their eyes so that they may turn
from Darkness to light and from the
power of Satan to God that they may
receive forgiveness of sins and a place
among those who are Sanctified by faith
in
me therefore oh king of grippa I was not
disobedient
to the heavenly
vision so wait it was a
vision correct so that means he didn't
really see Jesus if we follow the logic
of some of these guys right correct now
that would be Blasphemous wouldn't it
because that means that Paul never saw
Christ so he was not a true Apostle it
was just the vision and therefore he's
disqualified right yes which is
absolutely Paul tell us in 1 Corinthians
9 verse1 am I not an apostle have I not
seen the Lord correct but he says it's a
vision all right now what about the
resurrection appearance do they believe
that the women actually saw actual
angels and then they saw actual Risen
Lord in his glorified body of Flesh yes
well go read acts 2422 to 24 that's a
vision too Acts 20 uh Luke I'm sorry
Luke 2422 to
24 Luke 22 24- Luke
uh 22 um Luke 2422 to 24 what's
happening me Lord loosen my I'm sorry
Luke 24 22 to 24 my
apologies all
good again it's going slow here yeah
that's
fine now all of you guys listening on
his channel and on my channel go to
channel subscribe and like the video
make it go viral are you learning and
enjoying this this because I'm doing it
for your benefit if they repent glory to
God if not at least you guys will be
inoculated from believing their lies
yep well it doesn't want to load Sam
which is you want to use yep that's what
I'm gonna bring up
now L
24 yeah it's definitely Bible Gateway so
I'm going to use a different sure that's
fine here we
go there we go let me zoom in here so
you can get a better view all
right moreover some women of our company
amazed us they were at the tomb early in
the morning and when they did not find
his body they came back saying that they
had seen a vision of
angels who said that he was they saw a
vision of angels so that means they
didn't really see
angels for anyone that's trying to use
this argument correct so they it was a
but wait I don't think anyone would be
that sub Deni they saw actual Ang Angels
appearing as men and they actually saw
Jesus risen in his glorified physical
body but it's called a vision Paul sees
the Risen Christ it's called a
vision they're on a mountain Jesus
transfigured God the Father appears in a
cloud and they hear his voice audibly
it's called a vision now finish it
because I'm going to give you one more
example they were at the tomb early in
the morning and when they did not find
his body they came back saying that they
had seen a vision of angels who said
that he was alive some of those who were
with us went to the tomb and found it
just as the women had said but him they
did not see why I thought it's a vision
how did they discover an empty
tomb yeah that's where now the final one
final one read Daniel 7 13- 14 for me so
we're going to get to this later because
they're going to go here to try and
support one of their absolutely
ridiculous heresies okay that's fine
we'll do this and then we'll go continue
sorry it's takes longer to refute their
nonsense than it is to listen to them
folks so bear with us so if you have to
do a part two I don't mind Lord willing
okay yeah so Luke if you go to Daniel
713 to 14 watch
here Daniel sorry Sam that that's all
right Ian we
can't yeah but you're using a different
one right
yep it's giving you a hard time too
there no I got it here
okay so I saw in the night
visions and behold with the Visions
right night visions all right correct
okay and behold with the Clouds Of
Heaven There came one like the son of
man and he came to the Ancient of Days
and was presented before him and to him
was given dominion and glory and a
kingdom that all peoples Nations and
languages should serve him his Dominion
is an everlasting Dominion which should
not pass away and his kingdom won that
shall not be destroyed okay now this is
a vision so a vision means you won't see
things as they are it's only symbolism
then when Jesus in Mark 14 6162 is told
by th priest are you the Christ the son
of the Blessed Jesus said I am you shall
see the son of man seated at the right
hand of power coming with the Clouds Of
Heaven did no one give Jesus the memo
that this is a vision so why is he
saying you shall see the son of man
seated at the right hand of power coming
with the Clouds Of Heaven because after
all this was something that Daniel saw
in a night vision why does the Lord then
say I am that son of man who ride the
Clouds Of Heaven is Jesus taking that
literally is that what he's
doing you got it right yep I'm just
letting it based for the the audience
yep so that tells you when people tell
you it's a vision that means they're
biblically illiterate they don't know
the Bible they don't know the language
they should not be teaching they need to
be humbled and repent one more passage
About Soul that death happens when your
soul Spirit leaves Genesis 3516 to1 19
and we're going to go to the other
points because I want to bring up other
issues like Samuel and spir but we gota
wait because I don't know what's next I
really don't know I haven't watched this
gen Genesis 3516 to19 pay attention to
verse 18 why does she die because the
literally says as her soul was departing
not her breath it's her soul was
departing she was dying
then they journeyed from bethl when they
were still some distance from erith
Rachel went into labor and she had hard
labor and when her labor was at its
hardest the Midwife said to Hero not
fear for you have another
son and as her soul was
departing for she was
dying she called his name Ben onai but
his father called him Benjamin so Rachel
died and she was buried on the way to
epth that is Bethlehem now Lord willing
let me know when I can bring up other
texts like genesis 15:15 258 to9 with
Abraham showing you that he was gathered
to the realm of the Dead although his
body was buried somewhere else as well
as Samuel because I want to address that
to make it more thorough but I'm just
going to have to wait because we have
too much to cover I assume right yep and
it's going to get a lot worse okay let's
go to the next point because I do want
to deal with their blasphemy about Jesus
Christ go
ahead let's continue to read let's go to
First Corinthians chapter
15 it says moreover Brethren I declare
unto you the gospel which I preached
unto you and also ye have received and
wherein ye stand by which also ye are
saved if ye keep in memory what I have
preach unto you unless ye have believed
in vain for I delivered unto you first
of all that which I also received how
that Christ died for our sins according
to the scriptures what is the first
thing that we must know about the
gospel
CHR the first the very first fundamental
thing that we know about the gospel is
that Jesus indeed did die for our sins
amen right if Jesus didn't really die we
didn't have any we don't have the gospel
because the foundation of the Gospel is
that Jesus died for
sin right now let's go to two more
verses Matthew 20 verse
28 it says even as the son of man came
to be ministered unto uh but to minister
and to give his life a ransom for many
can we look at what that word what is
that word life mean in the
concordance life
g5590 so it's the word Su it's a word
that means soul and it also means life
so once again soul and life
interchangeable words but can I show you
somewhere else where that word Su was
used can we go to the book of Acts
chapter
2 verse 25 chap Acts chapter 2 verse
25 it says for David speaketh concerning
him who's the
H Christ I foresaw the Lord so he's
speaking about Christ always before my
face for he is on my right hand that I
should not be moved therefore did my
heart rejoice and my tongue was glad
moreover also my flesh shall Rest In
Hope because thou will not leave my what
my soul in hell what is that word Soul
meaning the
[Music]
concordance uh H okay let's look it up
uh H 5590 it's the same word Su which
means Soul or life right remember how
when Matthew 2028 Jesus said that I give
my life he gave his life as a ransom for
many but now this verse identifies where
that life was it says because thou wil
not leave my life where in Hell In Hell
neither would thou suffer thine Holy One
to see corruption when we look at that
word
hell what does it mean in the
concordance
okay
g86 um it's the word hell 10 times it's
the word grave it means the grave
doesn't
it yeah so or or it could mean h yeah
right so the Bible makes itself clear
that when Jesus died his soul or his
life all that Jesus was was in the grave
so Jesus was fully in the grave he fully
died all right so and this is why it
would do people like this well to at
least do a cursory reading of
foundational Christian teaching because
again we just saw the Apostles Creed
earlier no one is climbing Jesus didn't
actually die but Sam before we hear your
response what's fascinating about
Adventist citing 1 Corinthians 15 is
that Paul starts by declaring that the
gospel he preached he preached to the
churches in Corinth is to be kept in
memory because that gospel saves them
yet these guys's own official church
organs in this case the review and
Herald States stuff like this quote the
very fact that this Prophecy of the
Three Angels messages talking about
Revelation 14 covers the period between
1844 and the end of this age shows
conclusively that this three-fold
message is God's special message for us
at this very hour just as surely as we
are living between 1844 and the coming
of Christ just so surely may we know
that this three-fold message of
Revelation 14 6-12 is God's present
Truth for this present time the time for
this message is very definitively fixed
to the present
generation he who will receive this
prophecy as given by Jesus Christ may be
just ass sure that this is Christ's
special message for us today as if Jesus
were to appear in person and speak this
three-fold Proclamation with an audible
voice in harmony with this idea that
this message is limited to the period
between 1844 and the end we find that no
one prior to 1844 had ever claimed to
have given this three-fold
message neither Luther nor Calvin nor
Knox Wesley Alexander Campbell or any of
the other great lights of those times
set up the claim that they were doing
this predicted work of Revelation 14
6-12 if this work had been done by any
of them they would surely have known it
this prophecy of Revelation 14
6-14 does not and cannot refer to any
proclamation of the Gospel in the days
of the
Apostles the early Christian fathers or
the reformers of the 16th 17th or 18th
centuries it is strictly a Last Day
message applicable to those who live
just before the return of Christ close
quote so what the SDA Church calls the
gospel is their own novel message that
isn't what Paul preached and most
definitely is not what he means by the
gospel in 1 Corinthians 15 with regards
to acts 2:27 it was claimed that this
verse proves that all that Jesus was
remained with him in the grave this is
simply reiterating the Adventist
prophetess notice
folks
quote when he closed his eyes in death
upon the cross the soul of Christ did
not go at once to Heaven as many believe
or how could his words be true I am not
yet ascended to my father the spirit of
Jesus slept in the Tomb with his body
and did not Wing its way to heaven there
to or there to maintain a separate
existence and to look down upon the
mourning disciples inbombing the body
from which it had taken flight all that
comprised the life and intelligence of
Jesus remained with his body in the
sepil and when he came forth it was as a
whole being he did not have to summon
his Spirit from heaven he had power to
lay down his life and take it up again
close quote and this is supposed to be
in harmony with acts 227 nevertheless we
still have yet to see it demonstrated
that what Adventists assume is meant by
the word death is what the word means we
just got more proof texting where it
says Jesus died Sam 1 Corinthians 15
Matthew 20 and Acts 2 are the next proof
texts that allegedly prove the SDA
teaching about death is true your
response isn't ironic I already
mentioned the parallel to Matthew 2028
is Mark 10:45 but I'm really baffled
before I destroy their lies again now
notice even this friend had to correct
him he goes oh so Hades Hades means
grave right he goes yeah but it also
means hell did you catch it correct
because they're trying to impose one
definition but what I'm really baffled
here she says that Jesus's Soul or Jesus
Spirit slept in the Tomb and as she goes
he didn't have to summon his Spirit from
Heaven he had the power to lay down his
life and take it up again how if he's
asleep how did he do
that well not just that but again if you
look at their teaching on death
systematically again they're and you're
going to see these guys put this forth
here in a little bit like you did in the
intro Icebreaker where they're going to
because the aous Jesus was only a man
while on Earth so when he was dead and
he's just like we are he essentially
ceased to exist for three days and so
we're going to look at another quote
from her later where she contradicts
herself and she says only the father
could resurrect him and that's actually
more consistent with their system
because that's essentially the case and
I brought this up when I was in SDA
University to a number of the religion
professors and we always got some sort
of runaround and some sort of never
actually dealing with the problem of you
claim to be Orthodox in your christology
and to worship the same God that
Christians do yet you guys believe stuff
like this how does this comport with
Orthodoxy and it's just a bunch of
runaround so yeah this is blasphemy so
you guys I I assumed they were going to
deny that Jesus was God on Earth so
you're saying we're going to see that
confirmed okay now let me show you the
dishonesty of these folks number one you
saw even the lexican they cited says
that Hades which is the Greek equivalent
of the Hebrew
shol shol in Hebrew Hades or Hades in
Greek can mean grave or can mean hell
meaning the realm of the dead now how do
I know that when it says that Jesus's
Soul was not abandoned in shol because
it's quoting Psalm 168 to 11 if you look
at the Hebrew and Greek Hades that
that's not grave that's not the grave
but it's referring to the realm of the
Dead that means when Jesus's Soul left
his body his body was in the grave but
his soul went to the realm of the Dead I
want to show you a passage that's going
to obliterate them because I'm I highly
doubt they're aware of this brother I
want you to go to Luke 8 26-31 I want
you to see the word Abyss now depending
on the
translation the abyss may be translated
bottomless pit but it's the word abuso
abusos right it's the word Abyss okay
now watch here when the demoniacs
confront our Lord Luke
82631 they beg the Lord not to send them
to the abusos ab abuso the
abyss okay now you're gonna see what
that is this word is used in Luke 8:31
it's used in Revelation 9 and it's used
about Satan Revelation 20 verse 1-3 the
abyss or bottomless pit abusos refers to
the place where where demons are
constrained in prison and where Satan
will be bound for a thousand years
because I'm going to show you where
Jesus went when he physically died read
Luke 8:
26-31 then they sailed to the country of
the gazin which is opposite Galilee when
Jesus had stepped out on land there met
him a man from the city who had demons
for a long time he had worn no clothes
and he had not lived in a house but
among the
tombs when he saw Jesus he cried out and
fell down before him and said with a
loud
voice what have you to do with me Jesus
Son of the most high God I beg you do
not torment me for he had commanded the
unclean Spirit to come out of the man
for many a time it had seized him he was
kept under guard and bound with chains
and shackles but he would break the
bonds and be driven by the demon into
the
desert Jesus then asked him what is your
name and he said Legion for many demons
had entered him and They begged him not
to command them to depart into the abyss
remember the word Abyss abusos they
don't want to go there and these are
demons right let's see what the abyss is
go to Revelation 9 read the first 11
verses watch here watch where we're
going to go with this so they just lied
to you or they're ignorant which is why
they shouldn't be teaching the Bible I
hope you're listening if you are
ignorant repent if you're Liars the Lord
rebuke you and expose you because you
guys are Bible perverts you're
perverting scripture like Satan because
ellene white was of the devil may you
repent and Escape her snares for the
glory of Christ now watch this word
Abyss abusos Abyss what is this realm
read Revelation
91-1 and the fifth angel blew his
trumpet and I saw a star falling from
Heaven to Earth and he was given the key
to the shaft of the bottomless pit now
click on your a see what it is what's
the word see the a right there what does
it say Greek the abyss abuso same word
like in Luke 8:31 correct that you want
you remember the de demoniacs didn't
want to go there because that's where de
demoniacs are consigned until the day of
judgment keep that in mind so it's the
abyss right keep read now go back and
read he opened the shaft of the
bottomless pit and from the shaft rast
smoke like the smoke of a great
furnace and the sun and the air were
darkened with the smoke from the shaft
then from the smoke came Locust on the
earth and they were given power like the
power of scorpions of the earth they
were told not to harm the grass of the
Earth or any green plant or any tree but
only those people who did not have the
Seal of God on their
foreheads they were allowed to torment
them for five months but not to kill
them and their torment was like the
torment of a scorpion when it stings
someone and in those days people will
seek death death and will not find it
they will long to die but death will
flee from them in appearance the locusts
were like horses prepared for battle on
their heads were what looked like crowns
of gold their faces were like human
faces their hair like women's hair and
their teeth like lion's teeth they had
breastplates like breastplates of iron
and the noise of their wings was like
the noise of many chariots with horses
rushing into battle they have tails and
stings like scorpions and their power to
hurt people for five months is in their
tails they have as kings over them the
angel of the bottomless pit his name in
Hebrew is abdon and in the Greek he is
called apolon now what was the word for
bottomless pit
again abusos abusos so the abyss right
correct same word as used by our Luke 8
when the demoniac the legion didn't want
to go to the abyss right correct and
notice when this Angel open up the shaft
what came out came out locusts that had
tailes like scorpions right correct to
harm people for five months because I'm
going to show you these are demons in a
minute but now where will Satan be bound
in Revelation 20 verses 1 or3 the
bottomless pit which is the abyss right
correct show them so people don't think
we're making it up because you're going
to see where Jesus went what verses
Revelation 20 verses 1 to3 oh 1 to
three watch
here Bible gateways giv me our time
again yep then I saw an angel coming
down from heaven holding in his hand the
key to the bottomless pit and great
chain what's the word for bottomless pit
it's going to be AB abusos yeah the
abyss that's why I think you have a
letter if you click it I'll show you so
you can see y says AB right the abyss
yep you know notice this keep
going and he seized the dragon that
ancient serpent who is the devil and
Satan and bound him for a thousand years
and threw him into the pit and shut it
and sealed it over him so that he might
not deceive the Nations any longer until
the thousand years were ended after that
he must be released for a little while
Sam really quick just so you are aware I
don't want to Sidetrack onto this but
just so you know Adventists think
because the adven a system purports
because their Pioneers put forth this
supports Satan being the
scapegoat that this is talking about
Satan being thrown off the mountain
after the completion of the
investigative judgment and sin is
transferred onto him and he's cast down
and they say the bottomless pit is the
earth that's a that is desolate and
there's no one here for a thousand years
because they're premillennialists that
believe the millennial Reign happens in
heaven for a thousand
years so even though when we saw
Revelation N9 Locus came out to at the
tales of scorpions right yeah okay all
right so that means it's not empty
they're there are
demonic creatures in it right now who
are constrained and being tormented but
keep reading so what happens to Satan
did you read all of
it um yes okay so bottomless pit shut it
sealed it over him so that he might not
deceive the Nations any longer until the
thousand years were ended after that he
must be released for a little while now
did everyone understand I want all of
you to here Revelation 9 vers 111
Revelation 20 vers 1-3 Luke 8:31 Locust
like Spirit creatures with tals like
scorpions the legion the demoniac the
demons and
Satan are confined in this Abyss abusos
the bottomless pit did you guys see that
and if you want proof that these
locust-like creatures are demons with
tals of scir meaning they're demons
they're malevolent demonic Spirit
creatures who are confined but will be
released it's Luke 10:17 to 20 because
if you go to Luke 10:17 to20 verse 19
the Lord says he's given us authority to
trample on snakes and scorpions right
and no power of the enemy will harm you
well what are snakes and scorpions
demonic Powers
right you with me there yep okay now why
is this relevant because did you know
that Paul said that when Jesus was
raised from the dead he came out of the
Abyss Romans 10
6-7 he came out of the
Abyss Paul says when our lord Jesus was
raised
up
and was resurrected that he came up out
of the Abyss it's the word abuso same
word Romans 106 to7 so here Hades Hades
does it mean the grave it means the
realm of the dead so they lied or
they're ignorant and if they lied that
means they're of the devil if they're
ignorant they have no business refuting
anyone Romans 10 6
to7 Romans 10
6-7 so I know you guys are watching live
so did you know this then you're Liars
you're the father of the devil if you
don't stop rebutting you're embarrassing
yourselves go do something else go sell
burgers or car
insurance Romans 106 to7 sorry guys it's
uh he's got technical
problems
okay but the righteousness based on
faith sayso not say in your heart who
will Ascend into heaven that is to bring
Christ down did Jesus come down from
heaven correct like John 638 says for I
came down from heaven not to do my will
but the will of him sent me so Jesus
actually came down from heaven right
correct but then he actually came up
from the abyss because notice or who
will descend into the abyss that is to
bring Christ up from the dead did you
notice the abyss is the realm of the
dead but they're not dead in the sense
that they don't cease to exist do they
believe Satan's GNA cease to exist when
he's in the
abyss no he will after that okay but
during the time of the Abyss he's still
conscious right correct because he's
Chained and these locusts when they came
out they were alive in the abyss so
folks Hades doesn't mean grave Hades
mean meant that Jesus went to the realm
of dead meaning when those who die their
bodies went to the grave but their souls
went to the realm we call the realm of
the Dead Hades because it says Jesus
came up out of the
Abyss for those three days the Lord's
body was in the grave being preserved by
the Lord and his soul Spirit went to
that realm to proc claimed victory that
he had conquered the powers of Darkness
so why did they lie or are they ignorant
they don't know the
Bible yeah um now
Sam what they're trying to get at like
I'd mentioned is that the Advent Jesus
was only a man while on
Earth and set his divine nature aside so
notice the last time or we looked at
this uh I think the last time that you
were here one of the times this is from
the SDA organization's website on an
article titled what Adventists believe
about the life death and resurrection of
Christ
notice they say Jesus came to experience
life as we do as 100% human out of love
for every single one of us he chose to
be stripped of his glory Philippians 2
6-8 and was given no advantage over us
when it came to living a life without
sinning the word became flesh and dwelt
Among Us John 1114 but this made him no
less Divine Jesus was still 100% God
John 1:1 this concept and then they bold
it that Jesus is 100% God and 100% human
hypothetic Union can be
mindboggling but this was necessary in
God's plan to Deliver Us from the grip
of sin while the great controversy rages
on meaning both good and evil surround
us daily Waring against one another so
Jesus as part of the godhead had to live
perfect life then his innocent blood
could cover our sins and make it
possible for us to inherit eternal life
now here's the
kicker Philippians 26-8 says that even
though Jesus Is
God he set his divine nature aside a
Blas and took on human
nature so they try and pay lip service
to the hypothetic union which we will
hear these guys bring up later but
despite the lip service they immediately
contradict the hypothetic Union
by giving the kosis interpretation of
Philippians 2 and say that Jesus set his
divine nature aside and was only a man
on Earth so these gentlemen are trying
to prove that when it says Jesus died it
means he ceased to exist for three days
because he experienced death the same
way we do which they claim is a total
secession of any conscious activity we
did not hear that proven but let's
continue because we're going to get to
them bringing up Philippians 2 yeah
hopefully they bring it up let's deal
because I want to deal with their
blasphemy and I I do remember you did
mention this while but it's been a while
so that's good to know go ahead does
anybody else want to
continue yeah let me add to that because
some people are going to say that you
know Deontay um when you look at that
word hell g86 right it is the word Hades
and you know throughout the the Bible
it's it's if you look at different
concordances it's the word Hades it's
the place of departed Souls theer's
definition might even say the name of
Hades Pluto of the lower regions right
the grave hell like it can it can it can
be different things it could be hell it
could be you know Hades it could be the
grave how do we know which one it really
is because the concordance would allow
for all of them well the way that I like
to look at this is understand that the
book of Acts is actually quoting the Old
Testament right so when I look at this I
know that uh Acts 2:s 27 is quoting uh
Psalms Psalms
10:16 and let's look at it Psalms 10: 16
sorry Psalms chapter 16 ver verse1 yeah
I'm getting my numbers mixed up Psalms
16 ver10 it says for thou will not leave
my soul in Hell neither will thou suffer
thy Holy One to see corruption well the
word hell here when it was originally
taken what it meant was it can mean
either hell but it can mean grave also
again this is one to one and this is
where a lot of the concl the um
confusion happens right
because the way that the Bible uses this
word um and I think in the Old Testament
it calls it the word shio the way that
the Bible uses this word is as the grave
right if we look at the concordance like
most of the usage is grave pit Graves
that's most of the usage but then what
you'll see is
like people when they die they go to the
grave but what you'll see is sometimes
the Bible uses the grave in a metaphoric
way or in a symbolic way and so what
happens is there's a lot of confusion
that happens because people look at
these metaphoric ways of using of seeing
the grave the word grave being used and
say ah you see that metaphor means this
is exactly what's happening it's like
they'll look at the Book of Revelation
and think yeah scorpions are really
coming out or horses with men face
like those are real things but no these
are metaphoric things and so they're
supposed to be pointing to other things
and so what happens is we're seeing a
lot of confusion about what's real and
what's not God said that the day that
you sin you shall surely die right God
said to Adam you will go back to the
dust he didn't say anything about going
to a spiritual realm the things that
even talk about a spiritual realm like
the rich man and Lazarus is a parable
those are the type of things that people
look at and say oh that's real but it
it's not but when we look at this um you
know it says for th will not leave his
soul in hell and of course the word Soul
means life and the word hell means
grave okay yeah I'm G to have a field
with this I'm glad he mentioned that he
just buried himself now pun intended you
just buried yourself in your own grave
but go ahead you want to say something
well real quick so now you got to hear
from Dr Jason Thomas dude has a
doctorate of music not theology clearly
once again remember what Sam said in the
clip they played I don't want the people
to lose sight of this he was getting
ready to basically explain how Jesus who
is God can die he mentioned sda's in
passing to say their view of death
actually creates christological problems
in this area and as we have seen already
this is completely factual it does it
creates serious problems for the
hypothetic union that the two Natures of
Christ can never be mixed divided Etc
yeah what they're saying happened to
Jesus and death would divide the two
Natures of Christ that aside now they're
just spitballing about shol and Hades
something we didn't hear from you in the
clip they played let's engage regardless
he said there's confusion regarding
these terms because the Bible uses them
in metaphorical ways which is always
ironic coming from the hyper literalist
interpretation in adventism but only
when it's convenient of course but Sam
God told Adam he would return to the
dust and Luke 15 is a parable and not
talking about actual realities and Psalm
1610 supposedly proves the Adventist
teaching about the afterlife your respon
there's going to be Annihilation pun
intended they're going to be annihilated
really they're very bad I hope you're
listening live because you just buried
yourself and you handed handed it to me
by the grace of the Lord Jesus Christ
okay number one I'm GNA show you where
death doesn't mean ceasing to exist
because it talks about those who are
dead in their sins but no one denies
that they were consciously alive I'm
going to show you that Luke 16 even if
it's a parable doesn't mean it's not
true because he has the wrong view of
Parables if you actually study Parables
test me on on this parables are based on
everyday life experiences in other words
all The Parables of Our Lord are called
from actual
everyday activities done under the sun
on earth like a farmer who s seed and
these things are real they are
persons activities functions that
actually exist in the world so now that
particular Parable may not be based on
an actual event but the parable is
drawing from everyday life experience
and activities I don't know if you're
aware of this so cor let's say it again
no you're you're correct um and Parables
Even If This Were a parable um it
creates serious problems for them
because they need to explain to us
Parables use uh actual realities uh or
objects to describe real things so what
does the fire represent what does the
conscious experience represent what does
the torment uh represent if it's a
parable what do all those things
represent well they're going to try and
tell you that this is just a parable
teaching about the dangers of
wealth now notice he alluded to
Revelation 9 Scorpion's coming out or
Locust and he says well that's a
metaphor but a metaphor for what actual
living beings that are actually coming
out of the Abyss who will actually harm
Mankind and if you read Revelation 9:18
to 21 we see they're even likened or
they're identified with demons
Revelation 9:20 so point being yes I
don't believe that demons are actually
snakes and scorpions that I see every
day that I squash but that doesn't mean
they don't appear Serpentine or they
don't appear as as a scorpion or that
the imagery is referring to actual
demons that actually are in the abyss
that actually come out because like you
said they believe that Satan will be
actually in the abyss and that's not
simply a metaphor right correct so
notice how convenient it is Satan will
be actually in the abyss but when locust
come out with long hair like a woman and
a tail like a scorpion sting mankind
well that's a metaphor yes even if it's
a metaphor it's a metaphor describ in
realities that actually exist in an
actual place called The Abyss that
doesn't help your case so that's number
one now coming back to the issue of
death can you read for me Ephesians 2
read from verses 3 to
six among whom we all once lived in the
passions of our flesh carrying out the
desires of the body and the mind and
were by Nature children of Wrath like
the rest of
mankind but God being rich in Mercy
because of the great love with which he
loved us even when we were dead in our
trespasses made us alive together with
Christ by Grace you have been saved
pause right there so we were dead in our
trespasses but then we were made alive
so according to them does that mean that
we were no longer consciously in
existence until the moment we were
United to Christ and Made Alive well
what's ironic about this is they have to
make this some sort of metaphor or it
can't be actually an aspect of man's
being being dead
it has to be some other thing because
they are anthropological monists that
the only living aspect of your being is
your breath body combination so in other
words they don't follow scripture they
read into scripture their Traditions the
butcher but for those of you let the
Bible speak did you see what death
doesn't mean death whether spiritually
or physically doesn't mean secession of
life doesn't mean that because we were
dead in sins meaning we were severed
from fellowship and communion with God
who is the source of life because of our
sins but we're still consciously alive
let me explain what this is saying for
those who didn't get it God is life he's
a source of life but because of our sin
we were cut off from fellowship and
communion with God the source of life
but we were still consciously alive so
death does not mean ceasing to exist
whether it's applied spiritually or
physically but read it to seven because
I'm going to give you another one so
that in the coming ages
he might show the immeasurable Riches of
his grace and kindness toward us in
Christ
Jesus now go to Colossians 21-13 again
let me repeat what death doesn't mean
death does not mean ceasing to exist
secession of Life ceasing to consciously
exist death in this context means
because of our sins were cut off from
communion and fellowship with God which
is exactly what Ephesians 2 goes on to
say if you read it all the way to 22
correct it talks about the Gentiles who
are alienated from God who were
foreigners and strangers but now brought
near to God because Christ by his blood
has brought peace and made the Gentiles
and the Jews one new man reconciled to
God it's talking about being severed
from fellowship communion with God the
source of light because of your sins
cutting you off from fellowship with God
because God will not commune with
Sinners until and unless they repent so
here death doesn't mean ceasing to
exist when it refers to us being dead in
our sins so spiritual death similarly
physically dying doesn't mean you cease
to exist either and I'll prove that in a
minute go to Colossians 2
11:13 in him also you were circumcised
with a circumcision made without hands
by putting off the body of the flesh by
the circumcision of Christ having been
buried with him in baptism in which you
were also raised with him through faith
in the power working of God who raised
him from the dead and you who were dead
in your trespasses and the
uncircumcision of your flesh God Made
Alive together with him having forgiven
us all our trespasses now obviously it's
spiritual but it doesn't mean it's
metaphorical in the sense that it's not
real because unless you assume only the
physical the material matters then you
have a skewed understanding of what the
Bible says the Bible says it's the
spiritual realm the spiritual reality
Spirit that's real and the physical
material realm is a shadow of that which
is spiritual so if you think it's the
physical that's real then you're not
being biblical the physical the material
shadow of what is real the reality that
underlies that's the foundation of the
material Physical Realm and what is the
reality spirit because God is Spirit God
is Spirit by Nature he is reality
everything consists in God and that God
brought all things into being preserves
all things but God being Ultimate
Reality is spirit so that means ultimate
reality is that which is
spiritual so they got it mixed up and
they got things upside down so now we've
established here are places where people
who are dead are still consciously alive
and I've shown physical death doesn't
mean session of life and I'm going to
prove it from the example he gave of
Abraham I'm not going to give you
further proof that the story of Abraham
rich man Lazarus story of Abraham rich
man Lazarus even if you want to say it's
a parable still is based on realities
Jesus our lord is conveying the reality
of the afterlife that when you die you
to continue to exist because his
parables are based on everyday actual
activities and experiences that people
engage Under the Sun on Earth and here
he's giving you an example of what it's
like in the afterlife when you die and
I'm gonna prove it to you I'm GNA prove
it now brother I'm G to just give these
you don't need to turn there we know
that in Genesis 11 22-32 if you guys
read Genesis 11 22-32 Abraham was from
the or or of CI right y yep and that
would be in Shar meaning Iraq called
Babylon we then know that his father
Tera and him they settled in
haran yeah and his ancestors died in or
of Cala and his father and his brother
died in
haran then Abraham was told to live in
tents with his wife Sarah and lot and
his wife and kanaan right correct we
also know and guys don't take my word
for it we also know that in Genesis 3
when Sarah died he purchased the cave of
Mella to bury Sarah there and the only
one buried there was Sarah no one else
Sarah was the only one buried in that
cave Abraham's
ancestors his father mother they were
buried elsewhere his dad would have been
buried haran his ancestors Ro Cala keep
that in mind now watch what God tells
Abraham in Genesis 15:15
read it for
me as for you you shall go to your
fathers in peace you shall be buried in
a good old age wait it says as for you
you shall go to your fathers in peace
now notice the qualifier this is going
to confirm that Jesus is teaching Luke
16 is based on an actual reality he's
giving you an actual yep reality in
other words he's describing the
afterlife as it is notice he says
Abraham will be gathered to his fathers
in peace right correct Paradise
implication implication not everywhere
not everyone there is in peace right
correct you will be gathered to your
fathers in peace you shall be buried in
good old age now brother when Abraham
died he was buried next to Sarah in the
cave MFA there was no one else but it
says you'll be gathered to your fathers
where your fathers are you will be
gathered to them and you'll be in peace
but he wasn't gathered to them
physically because his ancestors were
buried in Earl of Cala his father ter in
haran but when he died he was buried
next to Sarah what does it mean that he
was gathered to his fathers in peace
where were his fathers for him to be
gathered there to be with them but he'd
be in
peace in shol the realm of the Dead
meaning this right here proves that when
Abraham died though his body was buried
his soul left his Spirit left and went
and to be United with the others who had
died because they all dwell in the same
realm it cannot mean physical burial
because when Abraham died his body was
not g gathered to the tombs of his
fathers let me prove that go to Genesis
to9 yeah now if we have to do a part two
let me know brother because I don't know
how long you want to do this it's up to
you no you're you're fine let's keep
going Genesis we got to get to
christological heresies and the Michael
the Archangel Point all right listen
that will be it
huh Abraham breathed his last and died
in a good old age an old man and full of
years and was gathered to his people now
before you move on brother notice what
came first he died and was gathered to
his people and then his body was buried
correct read all the way to 10 I'm sorry
I should have had you read all the way
to 10 sorry Isaac and Ishmael his sons
buried him in the cave of mechala in the
field of Ephron and the son of Zohar the
hittite east of
mammer add another verse on sorry about
whoops you're
good the field that Abraham purchased
from the Hittites there Abraham was
buried with Sarah his wife the only
other body in that cave was
Sarah but it says in verse eight when he
died he he went to his
fathers and then he was buried so what
happened first what came
first read that eight again what came
first him being gathered to his fathers
or him being buried next to Sarah
Abraham breathed his last and died in a
good old age an old man and full of
years and was gathered to his people so
when he died he automatically was
gathered to his
people right you see it brother because
you're like no I'm I'm I'm just letting
it based for the the audience I like to
let their their wheels and gears turn
let me know if they're getting it so he
died and gathered to his then the body
was buried but the only other body in
that cave was Sarah how is he gathered
to his
people well because because Abraham
wasn't just a anthropological monist
creature so guys ironically Genesis
proves that there is life after death
there's the realm of the dead so that
when bodies die their souls Gather in
that place now I'm going to tie in with
Jesus's Parable to show you that Jesus
was speaking of actual
realities what actually takes place when
you die and it's not simply a metaphor
because reread Genesis 15:15 for
me
okay
whoops as for you you shall go to your
fathers in peace you shall be buried in
a good old age notice he's will you
gather to his fathers first and then
will be buried
right and that's what happened right
correct he was gathered to his fathers
immediately when he died and then the
body was buried later with the only
other body in that cave Sarah okay now
notice it says you'll be gathered to
your fathers in peace implication not
everyone there is in peace lo and behold
Jesus our lord comes and
demonstrates and explains what this
means now let's go to Luke 161 19-25 now
it makes
sense there was a rich man who was
clothed in purple and fine linen and who
feasted sumptuously every day and at his
gate was laid a poor man named Lazarus
covered with sores who desired to be fed
with what fell from the rich man's table
moreover even the dogs came and licked
his sores the poor man died and was
carried by the angels to Abraham's
side the rich man also died and was
buried and in Hades being in torment he
lifted up his eyes and saw Abraham far
off and Lazarus at his side now before
you move on notice Hades here cannot
refer to the Grave because he's being
tormented and he can see Abraham elzar
now notice what this shows that when you
die though you don't have a body you
have a spiritual form and shape by which
you can still be recognized so the LA
rich man knew that's Abraham that's
Lazarus and they're there and I'm in
torment this is why the Lord said
Abraham when I gather you to your people
you'll be in peace because here you see
not everyone is peace in that realm
here's a man who's tormented but Abraham
and Lazarus are in peace keep reading
all the way
25 the rich man was uh also died and was
buried and in Hades being in torment he
lifted up his eyes and saw Abraham far
off and Lazarus at his side and he
called out Father Abraham have mercy on
me and send Lazarus to dip the end of
his finger in water and cool my tongue
for I am an anguish in this flame but
Abraham said child remember that you in
your lifetime received your good things
and Lazarus in like manner bad things
but now he is comforted here and you are
in anguish does that sound familiar
because God told Abraham I will gather
you to your fathers in peace meaning
you're going to be peace in peace there
meaning not everyone's at peace and here
our Lord confirms it here's Abraham
Lazarus peace resting comforted the rich
man who evil is
tormented that's how we know this
Parable is not simply a metaphor but
it's based on actual realities yeah
Jesus is
describing what happens to the dead when
they die they are still alive in this
realm some in peace some in torment you
can't get around this you're not sorry
for the noise I don't know who this
demon is all right but now let's go
deeper in the burial and The Cremation
and the annihilation of these guys who
think they're qualified to teach the
Bible I know what they're goingon to say
oh that's a demon go to 1st Samuel 28
11:19 now everyone getting this I don't
know about your channel they're getting
this yep all right 1 Samuel 20 11:19
because I want to show you the oldest
and interpretation of this chapter by
Jews in a book that was recognized even
among some Jews and many Christians as
scripture because it's found in the
death Sea Scrolls did you say 1st Samuel
20 28 119 oh 28
sorry yeah these guys are very bad they
thought they're refuting
me then the woman said whom shall I
bring up for you you he said bring up
Samuel for me when the woman saw Samuel
she cried out with a loud voice and the
woman said to
Saul why have you deceived me you are
Saul the king said to Hero not be afraid
what do you see and the woman said to
Saul I see a god coming up out of the
earth he said to her what is his
appearance and she said an old man is
coming up and he's wrapped in a robe and
so Saul knew that it was Samuel and he
bowed his face to the ground and paid H
it doesn't say Saul knew it was a demon
impersonating Samuel right correct
that'sa right correct now one thing
before you move on I want you guys pay
attention to the language of scripture
when the Bible talks about God and
angels coming to the Earth it says they
came down God came down the Angels Came
Down they went up right yep but here it
says that Samuel didn't come down he
came
up he came
up so he wasn't coming down because
there's clear evidence in Scripture that
prior to Christ's death Resurrection
Ascension the spirits went to the same
realm but this realm wasn't God's
Heavenly presence that only took place
after our Lord the hering the hering of
Hell techn harrowing of hell yes so so
but you notice it he's coming up but if
you pay attention don't think my word
for when God Appears or the Holy Spirit
appears or Jesus appears or Angel appear
says and they came down from heaven they
went up to heaven here it says Samuel
came up and he's gonna talk about it
keep
reading then Samuel said to Saul why
have you disturbed Me by bringing me up
bringing me up not bringing me down
correct Saul answered I am in great
distress for the Philistines are Waring
against me and God has turned away from
me and answers me no more
either by prophets or by dreams
therefore I have summoned
you to tell me what I shall do and
Samuel said why then do you ask me since
the Lord has turned from you and become
your enemy the Lord has done to you as
he spoke by me for the Lord has torn the
kingdom out of your hand and given it to
your neighbor David because you did not
obey the voice of the Lord and did not
carry out his Fierce wrath against am
therefore the Lord Has Done these things
to you or this thing to you this day
moreover the Lord will give Israel also
with you into the hand of the
Philistines and tomorrow you and your
sons shall be with me now let me the
Lord before you go on did you hear what
he said yep tomorrow you shall be with
me because the Lord will hand you and
your sons over to the Philistines and
then I'll read the last part I mean c
you go read the Lord will give the army
of Israel also into the hand of the
Philistines now let me break this down
just you can stop there right there let
me break this down if you read 1 Samuel
25 it says Samuel was buried in Rama
Rama Gilead okay remember there here
Samuel confirms to Saul you've been
rejected by God it is over God has
handed you over he basically committed
what we'd call the blasphemy of the holy
spirit because it's done with tomorrow
you and your sons will be with me
because the Philistines are going to
slaughter them now if you read The
Narrative you read all the way to the
end of the chapter it says that the sons
of s Saul were killed like Jonathan Saul
fell on his sword committed suicide now
here's where it gets juicy Saul was not
allowed a proper burial it says the
Philistines took the body of Saul and
desecrated it but he says tomorrow
you'll be with me well number one when
Saul committed suicide his body wasn't
buried number two the bodies of his sons
were not buried where Samuel was buried
Sam was buried in ramama Rama I believe
I keep saying Ram but it's in Rama not
Rama G I'm sorry Rama sorry I'm not I
suck with Geography 1 Samuel 251 none of
their bodies were buried where Samuel's
body was he was buried in Rama Saul
wasn't even buried until later when
David fetched the body because his
body's being desecrated but he said
tomorrow you'll be with me and
everything Samuel said happened because
the next day they were killed just like
he said the next day the Philistines
defeated the Israelites just like he
said but he said tomorrow you and your
sons will be with me how physically they
were not buried next to Samuel and the
body of Saul hadn't even been buried he
was being
desecrated what did Samuel mean that
tomorrow you'll be with me meaning when
you die and you're killed your souls
will join Jo me here where I'm
at just like when God told Abraham
you'll be gathered to your people to
your fathers because physically they
were not buried next to Samuel Saul
wasn't even buried for a while but he
says tomorrow you and your sons will be
and and you read next day they were
killed Saul committed suicide Spirits
left and they joined Samuel in the realm
of the Dead can't get around this now
and think about go ahead go ahead I
saying think about how absurd you have
to make the interpretation to use the
argument that sdas some sdas do and
Jehovah's Witnesses do that no no it
wasn't actually Samuel it was a demon I
was gonna destroy that that was my next
Point Let's assume it's a demon so
you're telling me a
demon is rebuking Saul instead of
deceiving him confirming to Saul that
God had rejected him and he died instead
of deceiving him into thinking no you
still found favor with God and then on
top of that the Demon's word came to
pass because the very next day they die
just like that demon said yeah yeah it's
going to get worse brother I'm now going
to have you look but you're gonna have
to probably use revised Standard Version
the book of serak now before they say
well it's not
scripture hear me out number one the
book of serak was found among the Dead
Sea Scrolls they
found three fragments of the book of Sak
in the Dead Sea Scrolls meaning the Jews
believed this book okay you say well I
don't care all right number two many
Christians believe Sak was scripture
you'll say well I still don't care
number three even if you do not accept a
scripture it still gives you an idea of
what Jews believe about death and the
afterlife and they didn't believe like L
G white they believe that when you die
you don't cease to exist why because
you're going to open up Sak 46 chapter
46 read 13 all the way to the end okay
and just in passing here
um for consistency sake as well Sam they
love to appeal to the Book of Enoch
which they don't believe is scripture
yet they'll appeal to the Book of Enoch
when it comes to uh the scapegoat for
example trying to say that it's uh
typological of Satan so just a little
inconsistency there it's GNA get worse
brother it's going to get worse from me
because I want to go to mcab I'm going
to show them the problems they have
there but go ahead remember Brothers you
read this is pre-christian
writing even if you don't accept it as
canonical it's still written by Jews and
this tells you that they didn't think
that Spirit was a demon because look
what it's going to say Samuel beloved by
his Lord a prophet of the Lord
established the kingdom and anointed
rulers over his people by the law of the
Lord he judged the congregation and the
Lord watched over Jacob by his
faithfulness
he was proved to be a prophet and by his
words he became known as a trustworthy
worthy sear he called upon the Lord the
mighty one when his enemies pressed him
on every side and he offered in
sacrifice a sucking lamb then the Lord
thundered From Heaven and made his voice
heard from a with a mighty sound and he
whipped out the leaders of the people of
Ty and all the rulers of the
Philistines before the time of his
eternal sleep Samuel called men to
witness before the Lord and his anointed
they're going to say see Eternal sleep
he slept not realizing it means rest
because Eternal sleep doesn't mean he
sees us to exist watch because here's
the proof keep reading I have not taken
anyone's property not so much as a pair
of shoes and no man accused him even
after he had fallen asleep he prophesied
and revealed to the king his death and
lifted up his voice out of the Earth in
Prophecy to blot out the wickedness of
the people so the Jew did not understand
sleep to mean ceasing to consciously
exist it means resting because they just
affirm that Samuel even after he died
prophesied
prophesied correctly that Saul would
die right
there now even if you don't accept it as
scripture as many Christians did and as
the Jews of the Dead Sea Scrolls did
this still tells you that the oldest
interpretation
the pre-christian interpretation
interpretation by Jews before the time
of Christ is that that spirit that came
out of the ground in 1st Samuel 2028 was
no demon it was the actual Living spirit
of Samuel who accurately prophesied and
the Lord honored his words even after
death because God had him prophesy after
his physical death and made sure his
words were fulfilled but let's make it
even worse for these Bible
butcher again you're going to say it's
not scripture but don't worry about it
because even if you rejected scripture
you're still stuck because I'm going to
show you that Jesus and Paul held the
same view go to Second mbes 15
11-19 second M 15 11-19 I'm sorry second
mes 15 11- 17 why am I thinking 19
because we're thinking about 1st Samuel
28 11:19 second mes 15 11- 17 now before
you read it let me give you the
historical background when you hit get
it up second mccabes 15 11:17 before you
read it the book of mbes are giving you
the history of how the Jews reclaim the
temple let me give you a little history
you guys got to know this history around
167 BC in December the Pagan ruler of
Syria Antiochus epes I4 entered
Jerusalem slaughtered thousands of Jews
took the temple defiled it by building
an altar to Zeus and slaughtered a pig
the Jews were irate at this blasphemy
and sacriligious act so then two years
later 165 BC a group of
Jews headed off by Judas mbes the mban
family Judas mbes in a zeil for the Lord
summon a group of Jewish soldiers to
fight the Syrian Army and God gave them
Victory defeated them reclaimed the
temple rededicated temple and that's
where you get Hanukkah the word Hanukah
means dedication it's celebrating this
miraculous victory of Judas mccabes and
his smaller Jewish Army who defeated the
larger Pagan Army and rededicated the
temple to God and they restored the
temple guess what date December
25th 165 BC yep December 25th Iran
the temple rededicated on December 25th
165 BC and the temple is God's selling
place and we're told that Jesus's
physical flesh body became the temple of
God and they rededicated the temple to
God December 25th 165 BC but watch where
I'm going to go with this in this
context there was a high priest named
onias who was killed unjustly he died
now Judas mbes had a dream a vision of
sorts and he's going to recount the
dream the vision to encourage his
soldiers God has given me a sign we will
win now pick it up from there SEC first
second mccabes 15
11:17 he armed each of them not so much
with confidence in Shields and Spears as
with the inspiration of Brave words and
he cheered them all by relating a dream
a sort of vision which was worthy of
belief what he saw was this now brother
before you move on you notice said it's
worthy to believe keep that in mind keep
going what he saw was this onus who had
been high priest a noble and good man of
modest bearing and gentle manner one who
spoke fittingly and had been trained
from childhood in all that belongs to
Excellence was praying with outstretched
hands for the whole body of the Jews
okay brother before you I'm gonna have
to stop you I'm sorry onias was
dead he sees in a vision the Dead high
priest onai is doing
what stretching his hands still praying
for his people on Earth but he's
dead now keep reading who else he sees
now look at the other figure he sees
then likewise a man appeared
distinguished by his gray hair and
dignity and of marvelous majesty and
authority and onias spoke saying this is
a man who loves the Brethren and prays
much for the people in the holy city
Jeremiah Miah the prophet of God
Jeremiah stretched out his right hand
and gave to Judas a golden sword and as
he gave it he addressed him
thus take this holy sword a gift from
God with which you will strike down your
adversaries you're confusing me he saw
Jeremiah the prophet who had been dead
at this time about 300 years because
remember this is written
around the second century BC Jeremiah
died in the 6th Century BC and he sees
Jeremiah alive and loving Jerusalem and
praying for Jerusalem and giving him a
sword in a vision and then he wakes up
and what
happens encouraged by the words of Judas
so Noble and so effective in arousing
Valor and Awakening manliness in The
Souls of the young they determined not
to carry on a campaign but to attack
bravely and to decide the matter by
fighting hand to hand with all courage
because the city and the sanctuary and
the temple were in danger
are you telling me Jews before Christ
believe that the dead in Christ those
who died in un with God like Jeremiah
the prophet are still alive and they
have a spiritual shape by which you can
still recognize them and they're
conscious and aware of what takes place
on Earth and here they're praying for
God's people on Earth according to this
yes but now what they're going to tell
you well that's not scripture well
that's not going to help you buddy
because our lord Jesus celebrated
Hanukkah are you guys aware John 10 John
102223 are you guys aware Jesus
celebrated Hanukkah well without the
book of makab you will not know what
Hanukah is the story of Hanukah comes
from first second mbes and there's third
and fourth mbes so number one our Lord
honored this Victory he acknowledged
that this war and the Victory won by
Judas mccabes and his Army and the
dedication to Temple was a miraculous
Act of God so he honored Hanukkah
because he went to Jerusalem when it was
Hanukkah and it was Winter read John
102223 for us okay John
10 22 to 23 yeah John 1022 to 23 and the
word dedication you'll have a note says
Hanukkah it was the Feast of dedication
AKA Hanukkah at Jerusalem it was Winter
and Jesus was walking in the temple in
the Portico of Solomon so the Jews
gathered around him and said to him how
long 23 2223 you want okay so look at
any note it's gonna tell you Feast of
dedication and the note will say Hanukah
notice it even tells you it's winter
that's when it takes place and when when
did they rededicate the t hanuk means
dedication the year 165 BC December 25th
and yet our Lord is
celebrating a miraculous event a
miraculous Victory not found in your 39
Old Testament books Adventist so the
Lord is amening this event but these are
the books that tell you that these Jews
don't believe like you they believe that
those who die their souls are alive and
conscious and alert and you can still
recognize them which agrees with Matthew
17:3 Moses and Elijah appeared which
agre with Luke 161 1931 so you got Luke
161 1931 Matthew 173 and4 2 mes 151 to
17 sirak 4613 following 1st Samuel 28
11:19 what more do you want both what
you accept as canonical scripture and
extra biblical sources telling you the
Jews did not think like you now that our
Lord and Paul believe this that Spirits
continue exist and can be sent to appear
to people yeah go to acts 236
to9 yeah they are the
Sadducees of today because it was the
Sadducees who thought when you die you
cease to exist not Paul who was a
Pharisee who agreed with the Pharisees
because there they were right angels and
Spirits exist here acts
2369 but when Paul perceived that one
part was Sadducees and the other
Pharisees he cried out in the councel
Brethren I am a Pharisee a son of
Pharisees with respect to the hope and
the resurrection of the Dead I am on
trial and when he had said this a
disension arose between the Pharisees
and the Sadducees and the assembly was
divided for the Sadducees say that there
is no Resurrection nor Angel nor Spirit
wait wait who brother brother when you
die there is no spirit because notice
Spirit here is not the same as
Angel isn't that what these Adventist
butcher
believe there well they believe in the
Angels but they don't believe that you
continue to exist as a spirit when you
die right correct the spirit is not a
conscious aspect of our being and they
believe that they believe that when you
die you cease to exist that's the belief
of the Sadducees right here correct they
don't believe in Resurrection well you
Adventists do they don't believe in
angels you do but they don't believe in
a spirit because you die you cease to
exist there's no Spirit left over but
did Paul agree with them that means you
agree with the Sadducees and Paul
disagrees with you because notice keep
reading for the Sadducees say there is
no Resurrection nor Angel nor Spirit but
the Pharisees acknowledge them all then
a great clamor arose and some of the
scribes of the Pharisees party stood up
and contended we find nothing wrong in
this man what if a spirit or an angel
spoke to him
oh we have no problem if a spirit spoke
to him like Moses and Elijah
appeared like Samuel appeared like onias
appeared like Jeremiah appeared we're
okay with that because we know they're
alive and God can send them with
messages not just Angels so we're in
agreement with Paul so they're telling
you Paul doesn't believe in your soul
sleep and how can a spirit speak if it's
not a conscious thing right but notice
they're agreeing with Paul they're
coming to Paul's Aid hey Sadducees why
do you got a problem with him that
believes that there are spirits and
angels and Resurrection we agree with
him Spirits can appear angels can appear
right and the dead are raised in other
words Paul just condemned you as
Heretics because you don't believe that
you believe you die that's it you cease
to be conscious not
Paul not Saul not the author of first
Samuel not Jesus Peter James and John
who spoke to Moses and Elijah not the
author of mccabes and these all Jews
it's over for you guys man the honest
thing to do is repent of your
Blasphemous perversion of scripture now
I'm ready for their blasphemy against
Jesus so we can take care of that are we
there yep well we're GNA be getting
there we have to hear now okay oh their
favorite favorite verse Adventist thing
how did you know how did you know all
right let's listen all right yeah when
we look at this let's look at
Ecclesiastes Ecclesiastes chapter 9 is
really where we can see what happens to
the dead persons it says this is an evil
among all things that are done under the
sun that there is one event unto all yay
also the heart of the sons of men is
full of evil and Madness is in their
heart while they live and after that
they go where the dead to they die right
for to him that is joined to all the
living there is hope for all a living
dog is better than a dead lion for the
living know that they shall die but what
do the dead know nothing the dead know
not anything the dead know not anything
neither have they anymore a reward for
the memory of them is forgotten this is
what happens to the dead there is no
knowledge in in the grave right there is
like when you're dead you the Bible
plainly tells you you know nothing also
their love their hatred their Envy is
now perished neither have they any more
portion forever in anything that is done
under the sun I'm going to add one more
verse to that whatsoever thy hand
findeth to do do it with all thy might
for there is no work nor device nor
knowledge nor wisdom in the grave
whether thou goest so the Bible is
telling us in the place that you're
going which is called the grave you
don't know anything and why I'm I I'm
bringing this up because when you look
at that word grave in the original Greek
language
8785 it's the same word Chio so now we
have a little issue here the Bible says
you will not leave his soul
in yeah so if you want to say oh Jesus
went to sh or Jesus went to Hades fine
that's what it says but what does the
Bible tells us is in
shio it says in shio there is no
knowledge no device there nothing like
the dead know nothing in the place that
you're going called shio there is no
knowledge there so now you have to ask
yourself this question how are you
looking at the word Chio are you looking
at the word Sho as hell where Lazarus is
and and and the rich man is having a
conversation which is a parable by the
way or are you looking at it as what
Ecclesiastes says shol is a place where
the dead know nothing and so this is
where all the confusion really is we're
looking at all of these symbolic verses
as if they're actuality instead of what
they really are symbolisms for something
but in actuality
the grave where people go the sh the
Hades where people go is a place where
people know nothing that is what the
Bible is
saying so where did Jesus go the Bible
clearly tells us that he went to shol
that's where he went Hades is the Greek
word for the Hebrew word shol and what
the Bible says about shol is a place
where they know
nothing oh I get so sick of heing
Adventists parrot this verse and think
it's just a a home run but Ecclesiastes
9 says the dead know nothing and since
Jesus was fully human in the Adventist
case only human wall on Earth setting
his divine nature aside this proves that
Jesus knew nothing while he was dead and
ceased to exist just to note Christian
whenever you hear Adventist appeal
here remind them that verse uh in verse
seven the preacher gives an exhortation
to be marry and drink your wine with a
happy heart because God has already
approved of what one does so put that in
your health message pipe and smoke it
but nevertheless there you go Sam that
sett you actually you hit it on the nail
this again shows I hope you guys are
listening you are Bible butcherer you
are tools of Satan I hope you're doing
it in ignorance you're going to repent
but if not then you are deceivers and
you deserve the Lord's discipline may he
have mercy on you if you guys don't
understand the point of
Ecclesiastes let me give you a breakdown
of Ecclesiastes if you start from
chapter one and you
read We Believe Solomon wrote it Solomon
is
describing Human Experience human wisdom
human observation gained Under the Sun
apart from Revelation in other words
he's showing the futility the stupidity
the vanity of human life apart from God
of human wisdom acquired apart from
Revelation this is why if you don't read
that
in light of what I said you're going to
have Solomon contradicting himself in
the same book and giving you ungodly
advice sinful advice and contradicting
other statements of scripture for
example he just said sh The Dead Know
Nothing real quickly he just has Solomon
contradicting can you read Isaiah 14 and
read for me
911 watch this argument again but Isaiah
1499-1
all
right shol beneath is stirred up to meet
you when you come it Rouses the shades
to greet you all who were leaders of the
earth Shades RAF means The Souls of the
Dead who are those Shades the leaders of
the earth who have died and gone there
reread it again 9 to1 shol beneatha
stirred up to meet you when you come it
Rouses the shades to greet you all who
were leaders of the earth it raises from
their Thrones all who were Kings of the
Nations all of them will speak and say
to you you too have become as weak as we
you have become like us your pop is
brought down to Shel the sound of your
Harps maggots are the bed beneath you
and worms are your covering okay I'm
confused how the heck do you have Shades
meaning their shadow of their former
self because if you don't have a body
you're less than human because you're
meant to be a spirit inhabiting a body
how are they speaking how are they
talking to the king of Babylon whose
body is now warm food but he's down
there with
them see now they created a
contradiction so then what are they
going to do well they say that's
metaphorical this is literal on whose
authority their own in other words
they're begging the question they think
they have the right view of death and
therefore when passages contradict their
C they'll say well that's not literal
that's metaphorical this is literal by
what Authority yeah so number one they
create contradictions but now they're
GNA impune Solomon of giving ungodly
advice because notice what you said
Ecclesiastes 97 he says get drunk right
be mared correct all right so is that
really God's wisdom that God wants you
to just party up party it up live a
hedonistic lifestyle no now can you do
me a favor let me hold on my phone is
messing up can you go to eclesiastes 712
let me show you how they're now going to
have Solomon contradict God's moral
ethical system and contradict himself
Ecclesiastes 712 what does it
say
Ecclesiastes
712 watch here guys that tells you they
don't know how to interpret scripture
this is why if he's a doctor what was he
a doctor of Music stick with music buddy
don't don't touch the bible again
glasses 712 what does it say wisdom is a
shelter as money is a shelter but the
advantage of knowledge is this wisdom
preserves those who have it so money's a
shelter huh okay now watch what he says
about money keep in mind money's a
shelter then go to Ecclesiastes
10:19
okay watch here how bad it's going to
get eclesiastes 10:19
h of course this thing yeah that's all
right if you got to use the other one
use the other
one
yeah Ecclesiastes
10:19 watch here
guys
okay Bread is made for laughter and wine
gladdens life and money answers
everything they actually believe this is
God's
wisdom money answers everything money
solves all your problems well if you
understand that the preacher is talking
about life Under the Sun and he's
talking about the the life of the the
wicked and that everything is Vanity and
that you're essentially chasing after
the wind and that you really should uh
the whole of of man is really to
essentially live for God and not the
things of the world um but when you're
handling the Bible the way that they are
here where they think the Book of
Ecclesiastes is basically a science
textbook that the preacher is trying to
tell you the anatomy of human uh of
human nature um well you're going to
make this silly blunder like they do
exactly you understand what he just said
the Book of Ecclesiastes is not giving
you God's perspective God's wisdom it's
saying apart from God apart from
Revelation if you base everything on
human observation experience then
everything is a waste you're going to
end up dead so make the most of it in
other words this is a manual for secular
atheistic
materialism because if he's right money
answers everything then Paul is wrong in
1 Timothy 6 6 to10 of being content and
not seeking to make more money because
the love of money is a root of many
evils and wine gladin so I should get
drunk so I can forget my problems that's
how they want to interpret this you see
how bad it gets but then if they were
being consistent they'd have to but go
to Ecclesiastes 510- 14 because here he
says money answers everything but now
watch what he's going to say
Ecclesiastes 510 to 14 yet name it claim
it
lanto name it claim
okay watch here Ecclesiastes 510- 14 see
this again tells you these guys should
not be teaching the Bible and they
refuted me huh allegedly allegedly and
they said they did so easily now you
know what's sad had it not been for you
they would have been living in their
arrogance thinking they refuted me
because I wouldn't even address them but
it's sad that they got your notice
because they got obliterated and
annihilated pun intended because they
believe in
Annihilation he who loves money will not
be satisfied with money nor he who loves
wealth with his
income wait wait no bro it says money
answers everything yeah didn't he say in
Ecclesiastes 10:19 money answers
everything y why is he contradicting
himself in Ecclesiastes 5 because what
do he say about money and wealth
now well that you won't be satisfied
with it
read it for us and see so but over there
he says money answers everything here he
says no read it again he who loves money
will not be satisfied with money nor he
who loves wealth with his income this
also is Vanity when good increase or
when Goods increase they increase who
eat them and what advantage has their
owner but to see them with his eyes
sweet is the sleep of a laborer whether
he eats little or much but the full
stomach of the rich will not let him
sleep there is a g this evil that I have
seen Under the Sun riches were kept by
their o by their owner to his hurt and
those riches were lost in a bad Venture
and he is father of a son but he has
nothing in his hand I'm confused brother
now you can stop there goes on to talk
about a son who's lazy and gluttonous
and he inherits what his
father uh busted his back for but I
thought Ecclesiastes 1019 says money is
an answer for everything but here is
saying no money is the cause of many
woes and see he contradict
himself but we got another one he
doesn't know the fate of an animal or a
human what happens when they die and he
doesn't know if there's an advantage of
being a human over a beast go to
Ecclesiastes 319 to
21 Ecclesiastes 319 to 21 it's gonna get
worse and I'm gonna tell you this is the
last book you turn to to get a Theology
of the afterlife and
Resurrection yeah read what it says
Ecclesiastes 319 to
21 this thing of course sorry here
brother that's sorry we got because then
I guess after this is Jesus right
they're gonna be yep by the way guys
catch it they just told you Jesus pretty
much ceased to exist you're hearing the
blasphemers these tools of the devil
saying when Jesus died he ceased to
exist he wasn't conscious so they are
blasphemers they're not Orthodox
trinitarians you're hearing it from
these tools of Satan Jesus could not see
CE to exist if he is still God on Earth
but they're telling you he did cease to
exist because that's what death is he
was in conscience which means not only
did he cease to exist but he wasn't any
longer God when he came to the Earth
blasphemy on top of
blasphemy for what happens to the
children of man and what happens to the
Beast is the same as one dies so dies
the
other they all have the same breath and
man has no advantage over the Beast for
all is
Vanity all go to one place all are from
the dust and through the dust all
return okay who knows whether the spirit
before you go on so okay man has no
advantage over the Beast NOP he's
exactly all die and that's it yep okay
now keep
reading all go to one place all are from
the dust and to the dust all return who
knows whether the spirit of man goes
upward and the spirit of Beast goes down
into the Earth so I don't know if it's
better being an animal or a man because
there's no Advantage we both die and no
one can tell me what happens to my
spirit or the Spirit by the way the word
breath is Rock the spirit of a beast we
all end up returning to us so maybe it's
better for me to be a dog at least I
don't work but hold on here he says in
21 he doesn't know whether the spirit of
man goes upward and the spirit of the
Beast goes down right
that's what it says right there talking
about the the yeah the the vain person
under the sun yeah but let's go with
them this is God's view right but then
he contradicts himself again because
notice here in 21 guys he says who knows
whether the spirit of man goes upward
you don't know that or whe the spirit of
a beast goes down but he sure knows in
Ecclesiastes 12:7 because look what he
says in Ecclesiastes
okay
Ecclesiastes
127 let's see see if this will work
again it'd be really nice if it would
yes
excellent and the dust returns to the
ground it came from and the spirit
returns to God who gave it brother but
in 21 he says who knows where the spirit
of man goes
dude help me I guess I guess he was as
confused maybe the writer was an
Adventist maybe he was uh just as
confused as they are wow so you're
telling me if we follow them then
Solomon doesn't know what he's talking
about and he's contradicting himself
left and right right correct because in
in ecclesiast 3:21 who knows whether the
spirit of man goes upward Spirit of
Beast goes down because we all go to the
dust who can answer that but he sure did
Ecclesiastes 12:7 so here real quick
real quick just so you can see it like I
told
you here's an Adventist in chat that
says what I told you earlier the spirit
is the breath so there you go it's not
me just saying this ADV do claim this
you'll get Adventist that say that's not
true Adventists don't claim that there
you go continue yeah keep keep helping
us dig your hole deeper for you but did
you guys see it if we go with what
Solomon said in ecclesiast 321 you don't
know whether the spirit goes back to God
who gave it all you know is you go to
the dust like the Beast so there is no
advantage of Being Human rather than a
beast in fact there are animals who have
it better off than us I know dogs who
live in mansions I don't live in a
mansion cats who live in a mansion but
then later on he says oh yeah though the
dust returns to the ground meaning our
body but the spirit goes back to God who
gave it but then he answered the
question that he said who knows the
answer because they don't know how to
handle this book now few more examples
because then I'm gonna explain the point
of Solomon you don't build your theology
on statements Ecclesiastes because he's
telling you the purpose of the book to
show the futility the vanity the despair
of trying to figure out things by human
observation experience apart from
Revelation you're going to end up
miserable and fact here let me prove it
to you you're gonna end up miserable if
you don't have God and Revelation all
you do is observe the world it's going
to leave you depressed look what he says
in Ecclesiastes 1 1618 a few more
references and we'll go into the Jesus
part Ecclesiastes 1 1618 right there he
tells you
yep I said to myself
look I've increased in wisdom more than
anyone who has ruled over Jerusalem
before me I've experienced much of
wisdom and knowledge then I applied
myself to the understanding of wisdom
and also of Madness and Folly but I
learned that this too is a chasing after
the wind for with much wisdom comes much
sorrow the more knowledge the more grief
so you're telling me it's a v vain thing
and a waste to pursue wisdom of God is
that what he's saying obviously he can't
mean that he's not talking about that
because that would be blasphemy correct
it would be blasphemy to say pursuing
knowledge of God wisdom of God is
madness and Folly and an only irritates
and agitates you because Jesus said
eternal life is to know the only true
God and Jesus Christ whom you have sent
and we're told in second Peter 3:18 to
grow in the grace and knowledge of our
Lord Jesus Christ because this what
happens when you have Bible butcher like
those guys who don't know the Bible and
should be shutting up but then if we
follow Solomon he doesn't even think
there is a resurrection because he
thinks this is all the life you have to
live do they agree with that what do I
mean here go to Ecclesiastes chapter
3:22 and then we're going to read
Ecclesiastes 9 1-7 we're going to read
verses
one four to see what he actually says in
context Ecclesiastes 3:22
so I saw that there's nothing better for
a person than to enjoy their work
because that is their lot for who can
bring them to see what will happen after
them yeah so all right what happens
after dying who who can answer that
question who can tell NADA that's it you
cease to be can you show me you guys
where Solomon believes there's a
resurrection yes you're using Solomon
teach Soul sleep I'm taking a step
further Solomon thinks this is the only
life you have to live and make the most
of it because when you die because
you'll never have a portion Under the
Sun that sh sounds like a gloomy message
where he doesn't believe there's a
Resurrection new heaven new Earth how
come you ignore that all right how about
right how about Ecclesiastes
612 it's like folks are you seeing the
problem with this Hopscotch complete
ignoring from the literary genre what it
is you're reading
etc for who knows what is good for a
person in life during the few and
meaningless days they pass through like
a shadow who can tell them what will
happen under the sun after they are gone
do they really want us to think that we
cannot know what is good for us in this
life so you mean forget God's
Commandments God's revelation who tells
us what's best for us what to do what
not to
do so they want us to believe that
Solomon's gloomy message of Despair is
God's wisdom and that's what God wants
us to think you can't know what's good
for you because your days are
meaningless oh well sucks being
you well that's how you'd have to if you
wanted to be consistent that's how you'd
have to handle the text based on the way
that they handle Ecclesiastes 9 to say
The Dead Know Nothing yep and now one
more Ecclesiastes 1014 we're gonna
reread Ecclesiastes 9 in context and
then we're going to see how Solomon
finishes it off so guys this is their
best they have nothing better
Ecclesiastes
1014 and fools multiply words no one
knows what is coming who can tell
someone else what will happen after them
yeah so who can tell what will happen
after them in other words miles can you
tell me what will happen after I die can
you tell me that there's a resurrection
and if I believe in Jesus I'll live
forever
I can but Solomon says who can do that
no
no no no no no no no Solomon just told
you three times you can't tell anyone
what's gonna have happen after they
die you don't know it's going to happen
well yeah I can hey brother you die but
the Lord will eventually return he's
going to judge living and the dead he's
going to destroy the wicked he's going
to us new Heaven and Earth and we who
believe will live with him forever no
you can't say that you don't know that
what are you talking about dude are you
on drugs now let's reread Ecclesiastes
9: 1- 7 now let's reread it and you're
going to see that at the end of his
journey of studying and experiencing he
says here is the duty of man here's a
conclusion so I reflected on all this
and concluded that the righteous and the
wise and what they do are in God's hands
but no one knows whether love or hate
awaits them all share a common Destiny
the righteous and the Wicked the good
and the bad the clean and the unclean
those who offer sacrifices and those who
do not do they believe that brother do
they believe that both the wicked and
the righteous will have the same faith
of course not but that's what he just
said in that very chapter that they
quoted right but that that doesn't jive
with a Bible Hopscotch Che of Jesus I
see as it is with the good so with the
sinful as it is with the those who take
Oaths so with those who are afraid to
take them so it doesn't matter brother
how you live you can break your Oaths or
keep your OES you can be Wicked and
sinful or righteous but you know what
doesn't matter this is the context
you're gonna die and cease to be that's
the context keep reading now this is the
evil and everything that happens Under
the Sun the same Destiny overtakes all
the hearts of people moreover are full
of evil and there is madness in their
hearts while they live and afterward
they join the dead anyone who is among
the living has hope even alive dog is
better off than a dead lion for the
living know that they will die but the
dead know nothing they have no further
reward and even their name is forgotten
their love their hate and their jealousy
have long since vanquished never again
will they have a part in anything that
happens Under the Sun go eat your food
with gladness and drink your wine with a
joyful heart for God has already
approved what you do you understand what
he saying you can stop there s do you
understand what he's saying he's saying
what Paul said in 1 Corinthians 151
12-19 if Christ has not been raised from
the dead your faith is in vain eat drink
and be married live it up for tomorrow
you die that's what he's saying why
would you guys read five and six and
ignore verses one all the way where he's
saying look apart from God in Revelation
all I have to
base what happens to mankind is from
what I observe then you know what it
doesn't matter if you're righteous or
Wicked it doesn't matter if you fear God
or not it doesn't matter if you keep
yours or break them because we're all
going to die and cease to be and will
have no portion Under the Sun he's
simply telling you that if there is no
God and no Revelation then there is no
advantage of being righteous over being
Wicked why should I be righteous why not
be a thief and steal and party and live
it up because we all die and we cease to
be and will never live under the Sun but
Brethren that's what Paul said in 1
Corinthians 1512 to19 what did Paul say
if the dead are not raised that means
Christ has not been raised well if
Christ has not been raised that means
you believe in vain your faith is
useless because you're believing for
nothing because when you die you cease
to exist so live it up eat drink and be
married because this is the only life
you have have that's what Solomon's
saying if there is no God there is no
Revelation and God hasn't made known to
us the fate of the dead then all we know
for certain is what atheists and
humanists and materialists say we only
have one life to live let's make the
most of it because when we die that's it
baby nothing Under the Sun and this is
their proof text that when you die you
cease to be conscious but now let me
show you that Solomon is showing you the
futility
of trying to gather wisdom from Human
observation experience without God and
His Revelation because then he tells you
no there is hope and here's the duty of
man go to Ecclesiastes 12 read 12-
14 and this was their best
huh yeah this is like their go-to
favorite verse be warned my son of
anything in addition to them of making
many books there is no end and much
study wearies the
body now all has been heard here's the
conclusion of the
matter fear God and keep his
Commandments that is the duty of all
mankind for God will bring every deed
into judgment including every hidden
thing whether it is good or
evil so he tells you after all that
after all these years of human
observation and it caused me depression
and left me without hope but there is
hope because God is real and God has
made his will known and here is the duty
of man fear Him obey him because he will
then recompense you for what you've done
on
Earth so there you go so that was their
best they have nothing the Bible
destroys and obliterates they're
butchering of scripture now I hope
they're doing it in ignorance and they
they repent if not not the Lord rebuked
them and Expos them because now we're
left with their blasphemy against Jesus
they've already shown you they're not
true Christians they've already shown
you they don't have the same Jesus
Brethren when they tell you that Jesus
on Earth cease to be conscious ceased to
exist when he died not only they telling
you they believe that when you die you
cease to be they're denying that Jesus
was God on Earth because if he was God
on Earth he cannot cease to be conscious
even when he died physically so they're
blasphemers they're not true Christians
let's let's go through their butchering
of scripture I may have to stop you at
key points because there are passages
where they're saying well I don't know
if he sustained the he was sustaining as
a man or not I'll show you that no he
was but
anyway but the issue is you know
um Jesus is a little bit different and
so this is where it's it's a little bit
tricky because he's saying he brought he
brought up some other questions he's
like well then who's running the
universe that's the easy question to
answer but then it's like Jesus is a
little bit different because in his
nature he is truly God and he is truly
man um let me show you some verses for
us to consider right in his nature Jesus
is truly God and he's truly man and so
the Bible tells us straight up he truly
did die and we do believe that he did
die you know and so who only have imort
imort talking about God dwelling in the
light which no man can approach unto
whom no man have seen nor can see to
whom be honor and power Everlasting amen
so God is the only one that is Immortal
and so when we look at Jesus's nature we
can look at uh Philippians chapter 2 and
this is honestly a very very difficult
question but this is what it says about
Jesus it says let this mind be in you
which was also in Christ Jesus who being
in the form of God though it not rob to
be equal with God but made himself of no
reputation and took upon him the form of
a servant and was made in the likeness
of men and being found in fashion as a
man he humbled himself and became
obedient unto death as a man he truly
died even the death of the Cross
wherefore God also hath highly exalted
him and given him a name which is above
every name that at the name of Jesus
every knee shall bow when we when we dig
underneath this verse right it says says
who being in the form of God what this
is saying in the original language uh
Philippians 2:6 it says being in the
form
g344 it's morphe form but if we look at
a Strong's Concordance it says his
Nature by Jesus's nature he is God
that's his nature but then what happened
he put on the nature of man it says he
took upon him the form of a servant and
made in the likeness of man he took on
him human nature so Jesus was truly
human and Jesus was truly God and you
know the Bible even talks about this as
a mystery it says in 1 Timothy 3:16 and
without controversy great is the mystery
of godliness God was manifest In the
Flesh come on that's a mystery justified
in the spirit seen of angels preach unto
the Gentiles believed on in the world
received up into Glory so there are some
things that is mysterious about Jesus
Christ even considering what he says
here in John 10: 17 and 18 He says this
therefore doth my father love me because
I lay down my life that I may take it
again no man taketh it from me but I lay
it down of myself I have power to lay it
down and I have power to take it again
this commandment have I received of my
father so this is a very mysterious
thing about Jesus Christ this is a very
mysterious thing because he's the only
one that could go to shio where is a
place that no one knows anything that
you're dead you're actually completely
fully dead and he's the only one that
could come out of that and live yeah how
that's above my pay grade to really
fully understand that because he's God
he's Jesus he has life inside of himself
it's a mystery but at the same time this
is what Jesus is capable of doing he's
capable of being fully truly dead and
still um alive for ever
more okay so now the mentioning of the
hypothetic union and Philippians 2 which
we saw earlier from the SDA Church's own
website is all lip service because the
Adventist Jesus was only a man while on
Earth and he set his divine nature aside
that's the SDA Bible commentary Ellen
White and their own website claims about
this paropy but folks let's also not
forget what else the SDA organization
uses Philippians 2 to try and claim
which Jason left out and creates serious
problems in conjunction with what we saw
earlier on their website notice signs of
the times an official organ of the SDA
church this is after they're supposed to
have their Orthodox christology locked
in in 1898 with Ellen White's Desire of
Ages she's still alive at this point
quote the Eternal Word gave himself he
did not aspire to be equal with God did
not Medi uh meditate a usurpation of the
Throne of the universe Philippians 2
5-7 but he emptied himself gave himself
then and there for Sinners he took the
form of a
servant becoming an angel among the
angels that he might redeem Angels but
they would not and when they rejected
the righteousness and life so freely
offered he descended low were still to
those duped by Satan Fallen man stooping
even to death that he might redeem of
the Fallen all who desire to be redeemed
and vindicate to the universe to all
eternity the character of
God that was the work of the word of God
the Eternal logos when he became Michael
the Archangel when he became Jesus the
man of Nazareth when he was anointed the
Christ when he died our sacrifice on
Calvary yet during all this time the
host of evil with all the baleful
deceptive cruel devices of sin were
hurled against him that God's character
might be marred that the great
Vindicator Redeemer might fall close
quote so the Adventist Jesus Took on an
Angelic nature not just the role of a
messenger but an angel nature and became
Michael the Archangel and he did this
allegedly to try and save the angels
that rebelled but they rejected him so
then he condescended even lower taking
on the nature of a man to seek to redeem
Humanity in doing so he set his divine
nature aside that he received in his
pre-earth exaltation to be made equal
with God the Father something that we
have looked at countless times on this
platform including when Sam has been
here again this is not a one-off a year
later in the same publication
quote he talking about Jesus Took the
nature of angels to repeat the first
step then in his humiliation in laying
aside his divine nature was to put on
the nature of
angels and thus it is that we have Jesus
brought to view as Michael the Archangel
the commander of the hosts of Heaven the
captain of the host of the Lord and as
such the armies in heaven follow him
when he became an angel he bore A
fitting name even as when later he
became a man his name befitted the
nature which he took by virtue of his
birth into our uh Human family that name
was Emmanuel God With Us his name as an
angel is Michael which signifies the one
who is like God whatever the name that
he takes in crushing sin and rebellion
in Redeeming the lost and in restoring
Harmony to the universe that name must
indicate that God is in him and with him
on the very plane and in the very nature
of the class of beings to whom he is
sent by by living the god life on the
plane of angels of which Satan was one
although Fallen he could neutralize the
force of Satan's accusations thus when
he became an angel the fact must not be
lost sight of that he was God with the
angels yet living on their plane
possessing their natures and this
thought is preserved in the name that he
bears as an angel close quote so the
adventage Jesus is a false Christ that
is not real this also evidences that the
SDA movement doesn't even use the word
God the same way that Christians do I
have said I don't know how many times on
this platform they use all the same
language but mean entirely different
things even down to the word God in the
SDA great controversy Paradigm you have
a Jesus that was exalted to be made
equal with God the father but then
condescended down and became an angel to
try and redeem the Angels contrary to
Hebrews chapter 2 that he doesn't help
Angels but The Offspring of
Abraham but these angels that rebelled
against Satan Jesus condescended down to
try and save them but they rejected him
so then he condescended even lower down
to the level of humanity to seek to
redeem them so Jason needs to study up
on his movements fake God and uh they
also need to account for the their
Jesus's Angel nature that he supposedly
has and any Appeal on their part to the
hypostatic union is merely lip service
that is unless they want to denounce
their organization's own website own
Publications and their own profetus now
Sam in spite of these insane claims in
signs of the times Philippians 2
apparently proves that Jesus truly died
as we have seen uh the whole night
meaning he ceased to exist and it
disproves the classical Christian
teaching on death your response yeah now
it's ironic guys I hope you caught it he
admits he took on human nature but he
didn't say he stopped having divine
nature catch it careful he was careful
took on human nature but he didn't stop
having divine nature and then notice the
contradiction did you guys catch it
contradiction he said yes it's a mystery
because 1 Timothy 3:16 Says a mystery I
don't know how he went to
sh right the place where if you go that
means you cease to be consciously exist
but he still alive I don't know how
because notice he had said it unless I
misheard him he's saying because he's
truly God he's living but he's truly
human and he truly died according to
their definition and if you're in sh
that means you cease to exist so he's
truly inal so he truly ceased to exist
but he's still Immortal and he's still
alive but that's a mystery I don't know
how to explain it so he's admitting he's
got a contradiction either you're living
or you are
ceasing to be you can't be both
alive and cease to be because to cease
to exist cease to be cease to be
conscious means you're not living you're
not alive he wants to have his cake and
E it too but here's what's
ironic up until this point they kept
appealing to lexans and in first Timothy
3:16 where it says great is the mystery
of Godly see it's it's a mystery he even
misappropriated the term mystery
Mysterion doesn't mean something
incomprehensible it means something that
was hidden but now revealed brother can
you look at the lexical definition what
does it
say a mystery secret of which initiation
is necessary um in the New Testament the
councils of God once hidden but now
revealed in the gospel or some fact
thereof the Christian Revelation
generally particular truths or details
of the Christian Revelation now what
does help's word study says the one
right beneath
okay the root of the English term
mystery in the Bible a mystery Mysterion
is not something
unknowable rather it is what can only be
known through Revelation I.E because God
reveals it and how ironic that they were
appealing to Greek lexans earlier you
see so did did you catch it the primary
meaning unless they can show us
contextually what Paul is saying this
secret purpose of God has now been made
known in the Incarnation when God comes
in the flesh our lord Jesus what God had
purposed that was not made known has now
been unveiled and revealed by God coming
in the flesh so I don't know where they
got that means now a better one would
have been
passages where it says that God is
beyond comprehension but now notice they
want their cake and eat it too so I
don't really know what to ref besides
the clear obvious contradiction because
they're saying he took on human nature
they don't want to say he ceased to be
God they don't want to say that he sees
possessing the divine nature but in what
they said about him not sustaining the
universe that's what I want to get to so
I can demolish that that means that if
he's not sustaining the universe that in
some sense he stopped being God or in
some sense they're arguing that he set
aside certain Divine privileges none of
which is what the Bible teaches because
their ignoramuses don't know the Bible
so the only thing I can now nitpick is
clear contradiction you're saying he
died truly a human death which means he
ceased to exist because if you go to sh
you cease to exist but because he is god
with a divine nature he's ever living
he's Immortal so he's both living and
ceasing to be so he's alive and not
alive he was continually existing and
ceasing to exist if this is not a
blatant contradiction I don't know what
is but are we gonna get to the point
where they say well he wasn't sustain
that one was a Oh that was oh yeah oh
yeah you ready oh yeah that's the part I
wanted to take apart yeah well one thing
on that
actually Jason read John 10 17-8 which
also backfires on them because
notice this is what I was telling you
about earlier yep Ellen White quote
Christ submitted to crucifixion although
the Heavenly Host could have delivered
him the Angels suffered with Christ God
himself was crucified with Christ for
Christ was one with the father those who
reject Christ those who will not have
this man to rule over them choose to
place themselves under the rule of Satan
to do his work as his bond slaves yet
for them Christ yielded up his life on
Calvary that's quoting the SDA Bible
commentary which is what they're they're
pulling the SDA Bible commentary is
pulling this from Ellen White continues
he who died for the sins of the world
was to remain in the Tomb the a lotted
time he was in that Stony prison house
as a prisoner of divine Justice he was
responsible to the judge of the universe
he was bearing the sins of the world and
his father
only could release him
close
quote so their divinely inspired
propheus claimed that only the father
could raise Jesus which is like I said
earlier consistent with their model that
the AVST Jesus only was a man on Earth
as we saw on the website and other
sources setting his divine nature aside
and he she also claimed that he feared
that separation was to be Eternal with
God the father and sin was so Grievous
that he wouldn't be resurrected all
other things that Ellen White claimed in
Desire of Ages and that we've looked at
both on your platform and while you were
on here Desire of Ages page
753 I believe it is Satan with his
fearce Temptations rung the Heart of
Jesus while he was on the cross causing
him to doubt the resurrection and he
couldn't see through the portals of the
Tomb and he feared that sin was so
Grievous that his separation from the
father was to be Eternal she contradicts
not just the scriptures with this quote
here but herself because elsewhere like
we saw earlier she claims that Jesus
resed himself even though he wasn't
conscious in any capacity in the grave
and he ceased to exist for 3 Days
nevertheless this was just more
pontificating and reading proof text on
their part it has not been demonstrated
yet that what sdas assume in the word
death is that that means a total
cessation of any conscious activity
whatsoever and that you're only
remembered in the mind of God um to then
possibly have your character ported into
a new body that the Adventist God will
make for you if you were found worthy of
Salvation helping vindicate the the
Adventist God against Satan from these
accusations in the great controversy
because Sam they don't actually believe
in true
Resurrection they believe that God is
going to make INF fashion a new body and
Infuse into that new body of new
particles your character from his memory
at a later point in the
future not that not that what was sewn
into the ground like Paul says in 1
Corinthians 15:42 that what is sown is
then raised it's first sown to then be
raised now you're obviously going to get
Adventists on this that say that's not
true yes it is that's what the SDA Bible
commentary says and that is what this is
what they are pulling from this is Ellen
White on this exact subject I got to
read this quote because again you know
that there's going to be Adventists that
say that's not
true here it is personality preserved in
a new body
our personal identity is preserved in
the resurrection though not the same
particles of matter or material
substance as when into the grave the
wondrous works of God are a mystery to
man The Spirit the character of man ah
another way that they use the term
spirit is return to God there to be
preserved in the resurrection every man
will have his own
character God in his own time will call
forth the dead giving again the Breath
of Life there you see it Sam and bidding
the dry bones live the same form will
come forth but it will be free from
disease and every defect it lives again
bearing the same individuality of
features so that friend will recognize
friend there is no law of God in nature
which shows that God gives back the same
identical particles of matter which
compose the body before death God shall
give the righteous a body that will
please
him no they don't believe in
Resurrection they believe in something
closer to
cloning just like Joe's Witnesses they
believe exact because Charles ta Russell
was influenced by the millerites the
Adventists they believe the same exact
thing yep same exact thing difference is
as they will claim that their
trinitarians whereas yours witnesses
will say no Jesus was created as a first
of God's creation brought into existence
which is the initial original belief of
the Adventists that's what they believe
correct yep so all right well let's get
back into this now we're gonna get into
what you were just asking about but um I
do want to get into how is he able to
run the universe while being dead did
you guys want to do that because I do
have an answer for that yeah and um I
think uh simply F show um basically just
asked this question so let's let's
answer that question so Sam shamon said
how could the universe run or who's
running the universe if Jesus died but
you know I could ask Sam Shimon the same
question who was running the universe
when Jesus was a fetus in the
womb who was running the universe when
Jesus was an infant as a matter of fact
let's look at what the Bible says the
Bible says in Luke 2 verse
52 the Bible says and Jesus increased in
wisdom and stature and favor with God
and man so we understand that Jesus
although he was fully God 100% fully God
in his human form there were points in
his Boyhood where he didn't just know
everything we understand that Jesus
growing up had to learn things correct
so we understand that at at certain
points that you know Jesus was not
running the
Universe I wish you had that folks yep
catch that I wish he had asked me that
question because friend I would have
pulverized you and buried you if you
asked me who was running the universe
when Jesus was an embryo in his mother's
womb or a child I would have buried you
for being a tool of Satan and a
blasphemer here's my my answer
Jesus Jesus as God one with the father
and the spirit never stopped sustaining
Creation with the father and the Spirit
by his powerful word so that while being
conceived in his mother's womb he was
sustaining preserving both his mother
and his own human nature and even while
he was a toddler as God he never sees
sustaining creation and yet as a man he
grew but because you're a Bible
butcherer you don't know scripture it
says the same Jesus who on Earth knew
everything so let's go through this
destruction of this
blasphemy okay now brother go to Hebrews
1 and I want you to read for me verses
two to three see these guys are not
Christians they're tools of Satan so I
wish you had asked me that I would say
Jesus Jesus was sustaining his mother
Jesus was sustaining her body Jesus was
sustaining his human nature his physical
body with the father spirit not alone
all three the one God and Jesus while
even as a toddler by virtue being God is
preserving all creation and his own body
his own human nature his own human soul
and mind with the father and spirit here
let me prove it go to Hebrews 1 verses 2
to
3 but in these last days he has spoken
to us by his son whom he appointed heir
of all things and through whom also he
made the universe the sun is the
radiance of God's glory glory and the
exact representation of his being
sustaining All Things by his powerful
word after he had provided purification
for sins he sat down at the right hand
of the Majesty in heaven now watch here
two says that God the father created the
ages through the sun and the son
sustains all the ages by his powerful
word by his
command now notice nothing in that
passage indicates he stopped doing so
during the time he offered purification
for our sins nothing in point of fact in
verses 10 to 12 the father addressing
the son says that's something impossible
for Christ in other words Christ being
God could never at any moment stop
sustaining all creation even during his
time on the earth because look what the
father says to the son in Hebrews 1:10
to12
he also says in the beginning Lord you
lay the foundations of the earth and the
heavens are the work of your hands they
will perish but you remain they will
wear out like a
garment you will roll them up like a
robe like a garment they will be changed
but you remain the same and your years
will never end not according to these
blasphemers here the father says to the
son quoting Psalm 102 you are the Lord
who laid the foundations of the earth
and you made the heavens by the work of
your hands your power you remain the
same on like creation that's changing
you roll them up but you are the same
your years never end that means if this
is true from the moment Christ with the
father and spirit created the heavens
and the Earth has never stopped
sustaining creation because he Remains
the Same and his years never end and he
doesn't
change therefore that means this one
Eternal Divine person though he entered
the world became flesh by virtue of
being God he remains consistently The
God Who sustains creation even during
his time on earth when he was conceived
by the Virgin grew and died on the cross
at no point does it say he stopped I'm
going to prove it from the gospels go to
Colossians 1 16-
17 in fact Colossians 1 read 16
20 okay now everyone else listening are
you we have about 500 yours and mine
combined about 500 so glory to God made
the numbers increase and you get more
traffic now everyone understand what my
answer
is yeah read Colossians 1 16 to
20 for in him all things were created
things in heaven and on Earth visible
and invisible whether Thrones or powers
or rulers or authorities all things have
been created through him and for him he
is before all things and in him all
things hold together yep and he is the
head of the body the church he is the
beginning and the firstborn from among
the dead so that in everything he might
have the
supremacy for God was pleased to have
all his fullness dwell in him and
through him to reconcile to himself all
things whether things on earth or things
in Heaven by making peace through his
blood shed on the cross now brotherr in
verse 17 says he is present tense not
was he is
currently before all things meaning not
only he's uncreated but he's Supreme
over all things but then it says it's in
him all things consist that he has the
creative power that enables him to
sustain every part of creation but then
in verses 19 to 20 says even while he
was
reconciling all things on earth and in
heaven to God the Father by the blood of
his cross even during that time God's
fullness was still dwelling in him so
when did he stop sustaining and
preserving creation never at no point in
time he has never stopped so this guy is
a Bible butcherer and a blasphemer and I
hope he repents and not be stubborn
because that was a wicked Blas shows you
need to stop you're dangerous you're of
the devil may you repent before the Lord
reuk you all right still not convinced
let me show you now that Jesus while on
Earth was still all knowing while on
Earth was still omnipresent while on
Earth go to John 16
25-31 a knew exactly where we were going
because you see he now that you speak
clearly yes but you see he was quoting
passages where Jesus as truly human grew
in wisdom stature that's true but
because he's didn't stopped being God he
was still all knowing it's both and not
either or you Bible perverts John 231
but notice remember two earlier they
tried to appeal to the hypothetic union
they tried to say that Adventists just
like the website says we believe in the
hypothetic union no you don't it's all
just lip service you don't know what
that means and this is going to prove
it though I have been speaking
figuratively Jesus speaking here a time
is coming when I will no longer use this
kind of language but will tell you
plainly about my father in that day you
will ask in my name I'm not saying that
I will ask the father on your behalf
know the father himself loves you
because you have loved me and have
believed that I came from God I came
from the father and entered the world
now I'm leaving the world and going back
to the
father then Jesus's disciples said now
you're speaking clearly and without
figures of speech
now we can see that you know all
things and that you do not even need to
have anyone ask you questions this makes
us believe that you came from God do you
now believe Jesus replied so notice he
doesn't rebuke them but notice they
can't tap dance around this you're not
speaking figuratively metaphorically
Adventist nope you're speaking clearly
and because of that now we know you know
all things and he's on Earth and you
don't need anyone question you meaning
you don't need anyone to question you to
test to see if you know what you're
talking about we now are convincing in
all things and Jesus says that you
finally believe it took you a while so
before his death and Resurrection on
Earth he knew all things even after his
resurrection same group of disciples
This Time Peter what does he say in John
21:7 before and after what does it how
did I know that you were going there
because Brilliant Minds think like and
you're brilliant Mis the third time he
said to him Simon son of John do you
love me Peter was hurt because Jesus
said to or asked him the third time do
you love
me he said Lord you know all things you
know that I love you Jesus said feed my
sheep now we know that Peter means it
literally because why because it says he
got hurt he asked him three times so
then that proms him say Lord you already
know everything you know all things you
know if I love you or not why do you
keep asking so it cannot be metaphorical
you are the Lord who knows everything
you already know if I love you or not so
why ask me three times so before and
after the resurrection he knows all
things okay now keep that in mind he
knows all things now go to Luke 10:22 we
got a few oh I guessed 1 John 3:20 yes
well that's God knows everything but I'm
focusing on Jesus because that's John
320 because that's God they'll say
that's God the Father I'm focusing on
Jesus because that's for first John 320
God right knows everything but they'll
say yeah that's God the Father no I'm
talking about Christ who's God the son
and hypostatic Union if you guys don't
know what that means folks he's one
Divine person who unites two Natures but
neither nature right ceased to be in him
he was still truly fully God truly fully
human so either you don't know what
apostatic Union is or are you again
paying lip service now watch watch here
Luke
10:22 all things have been committed to
me by my father no one knows who the son
is except the father and no one knows
who the father is except the son and
those to whom the son chooses to reveal
him now if I ask you a question here
while on Earth before his death and
Resurrection he says the father is the
only one who knows the Son and the only
one able to know the son now if I ask
you does the father know the son inside
and out every aspect of the son every
thought of the
son yes but Jesus says it's reciprocal
the way the father knows me I know the
father and only the father knows me and
I alone know the father in the same way
the father knows me that mean Jesus just
claimed while on Earth he knows the
father inside and out every aspect of
the father every thought of the father
but the father's infinite and omnicient
how can he know the Father the same way
the father knows him without this making
him omniscient because it takes an
omniscient mind to know an infinite
being or an infinite person in this case
because their being is the same and then
he claims to be incomprehensible like
the father just like no one can
comprehend the father if you're a
creature but I'm no mere creature
likewise no one can comprehend me and
this is why he's on
earth now go to John 22325 we got a few
that Christ was omnipresent even on
Earth okay John
22325 yep show you now he's omnipresent
even on
earth now while he was in Jerusalem at
the Passover Festival many people saw
the signs he was performing and believed
in his name but Jesus would not entrust
himself to them for he knew all people
he did not need any testimony about
Mankind for he knew what was in each
person did you catch it he knew
all he knows everyone he knows what's in
each person he knows all things doesn't
need to be questioned he knows the
father to the same set the father knows
him and this is on Earth before his
death and Resurrection was he
omnipresent on earth now let me explain
what we mean physically bodily Jesus is
located in one place at one time but
because he didn't cease to be God as God
he is the everpresent all knowing
Creator and sustainer and he has to be
everpresent if he's still sustaining
every part of creation while on Earth
and here's the proof go to John 4 read
for US 43 to 54 so we got three more
texts this one and two others what was
it John 4:43 to 54 pay attention Christ
physically on
Earth because he's God didn't cease to
be God overseeing creation
superintending creation is able to do
Miracles without physically being there
watch after the two days he left for
Galilee now Jesus himself had pointed
out that a prophet has no honor in his
own country when he arrived in Galilee
the galileans welcomed him they had seen
all that he had done in Jerusalem at the
Passover festival for they also had been
there once more he visited kaaa in
Galilee where he had turned the water
into wine and there was a certain Royal
official whose son lay sick in
Capernaum when this man heard that Jesus
had arrived in Galilee from Judea he
went to him and begged him to come and
heal his son who was close to death now
pay attention brother he begged Jesus to
do the miracle right so come down
correct yep keep
going folks you know where this is going
because we talk about this a lot on here
and I bring this up a lot unless you
people see signs and wonders Jesus told
him you will never believe the Royal
official said sir come down before
before my child dies go Jesus replied
your son will live the man took Jesus at
his word and departed while he was still
on the way his servants met him with the
news that his boy was living when he
inquired as to the time when his son got
better they said to him yesterday at 1
in the afternoon the fever left him then
the father realized that this was the
exact time at which Jesus J had said to
him your son will live so he and his
whole household believed this was the
second sign Jesus performed after coming
from Judea to Galilee
meaning he went on a he went on a
multi-day
journey and he was traveling to see
Jesus asked him to heal his son Jesus
said go your son will live on his
journey back his men yep his men meet
him and he finds out that his son was
healed he asks when and he finds out it
was that the exact hour that Jesus
himself who did the healing not the Holy
Spirit not the
father had done the healing but was not
physically present with the boy he said
go your son lives so he knew his son
would Liv because he had healed
him but the son was a day away from
Jesus physically so that's one example
let's go to the other example there's
two more john: 145 to 49 you got a guy
mark V who's shaken he's losing faith in
SDA on my channel I sent you a private
chat so go to answering adventism
website uh YouTube channel brother
here's the other one John 145 to 49 yep
the Fig
Tree and now I'll give you another one
because these are ones I brought up in
the past but so he's still omnipresent
he's still omniscient he's still
omnipotent because notice he's got to be
present ever if he's still overseeing
and preserving creation which is why he
doesn't have to be physically there to
command demons and healing because he's
overseeing creation he's in control
while on Earth physically John
14549 Philip found Nathaniel and told
him we found the one Moses wrote about
in the law and about whom the prophets
also wrote Jesus of Nazareth the son of
Joseph Nazareth can anything good come
from there Nathaniel asked come and see
said Phillip when Jesus saw Nathaniel
approaching he said to to him here truly
is an Israelite in whom there is no
deceit how do you know me Nathaniel
asked Jesus
answered I saw you while you were under
the tree emphasize I saw you correct
before Philip came and called you while
he sitting on the Fig Tree keep going
then Nathaniel declared Rabbi you are
the Son of God and are the king of
Israel now break it down miles why would
he be shocked that Jesus knew him
already remember it said in John
22325 Jesus knew all he knew what was in
every man he already knew what was in
Nathaniel without even having seen him
physically because it's their first
physical encounter he already knew what
was in him and he already saw him what
does that
mean Nathaniel finds him and clearly
knows that Jesus is not this individual
is not physically present with them he
then goes to meet this individual that
he's probably been taught his whole life
um is the Messiah or or rather he's been
taught about the Messiah his whole life
and now somebody's coming to him and
telling him yo the messiah's here so
they get up they go to where he is and
Jesus tells him this that he saw him
under the Fig Tree at which Nathaniel's
or or uh his his mind is blown
Nathaniel's mind is blown because he
knows that Jesus was not physically
present there yet he tells him that he
saw him under the Fig Tree and he knew
what was in him like John 22325 says he
knew all men he already knows what's in
man he already knew Nathaniel knew what
was in Nathaniel without having met him
now the final one well not just that but
then the following verse after this
where Jesus continues to go on uh right
it continues and he says if you're
really like blown away by this you're
going to see things far beyond this that
are going to blow your mind yeah you're
going to see Angels ascending descending
upon the son of man John 15051 final
example that Christ is omnipresent on
Earth that he didn't cease to be God in
all his fullness Mark 7:2
24-30 there you go so he never stopped
being God he didn't stop being omnicient
omnipresent omnipotent but now I don't
want them to TA St man we don't believe
Jesus worked alone he with the father
and spirit all three of them together as
one God did all the
Miracles and and in conjunction with
Colossians 1 which says the fullness of
deity dwelt in him bodily yep on Earth
as he was reconciling all things on the
cross which took place on Earth
correct Jesus left that place and went
to the vicinity of Ty he entered a house
and did not want anyone to know it yet
he could not keep his presence Secret in
fact as soon as she heard about him a
woman whose little daughter was
possessed by an impure Spirit came and
fell at his feet the woman was a Greek
born in s uh Syrian Phoenicia she begged
Jesus to forgive the demon out of or to
drive the demon out of her daughter
first let the children eat all they want
he told her for it is not right to take
the children's bread and to toss it to
the dogs Lord she replied even the dogs
under the table eat the children's
crumbs then he told her for such a reply
you may go the demon has left your
daughter she went home and found her
child lying on the bed and the demon go
gone you guys caught it right he wasn't
there physically she's asking him doing
a miracle go the Demon's already gone
because he already got rid of the demon
though he wasn't physically
there and it's Jesus doing the casting
out of the
demon so everyone caught it right he's
doing it and he's telling her he's
already gone or like when he told the
man your son lives he's already taken
care of it go I've seen you before
Philip came to you he never stopped
being the fullness of God while on Earth
anyone who teaches otherwise blasphemy
now I don't know what else they have is
that it or they got more they got more
but let's uh let's finish that up in a
part two I feel like we've done a a
plenty good decimation here we can
finish this off maybe you can come back
next week if you are available and we
can we can finish this off and then
again folks now you're seeing why uh
this platform ignores these individuals
it almost feels like we are punching
down um but they want to bark like dogs
they want to be arrogant they want to
act like they um have it all figured out
um they decimated Sam um they've
decimated answering adventism and uh for
any honest person tonight I think it's
very clear um this is simply a cope they
are coping um and so gentlemen I know
that you are watching this if your
stream is still going I don't know if it
is and I'm not going to watch your silly
stream you had the opportunity to come
over here just like you did months ago
before you started doing your silly
summonsing where you claimed that people
to come and stand before you like you're
some sort of Monarch or something like
that you guys didn't show up and instead
started saying I need to show up to your
platform or I'm scared yeah we're not
playing little kindergarten games I'm
not doing all that you had the
opportunity to come over here tonight
since you wanted to get the guy who was
originally supposed to be here to not
show up and you guys didn't show up
instead you sat in your bunker and you
shot spitballs like I said from your
spiritual squirt guns I'm sure and made
all sorts of silly claims and arguments
but I think for tonight this is was a a
plenty plenty good burial that's why I
don't watch these guys let you know guys
you guys let me be honest you're Bible
butcher you're neop fites you're
biblically illiterate you are the very
people that Peter warned against in
second Peter 3:15-16 unstable untaught
you distort the scripture to your
humiliation now I pray you're doing it
in ignorance you'll be convicted repent
but if you double down the Lord rebuke
you and protect people from you false
teachers the Lord bless this young man
bless me to walk worthy of Jesus in the
power of the Holy Spirit never shame the
Lord finish the race and that Jesus our
lord will be magnified in and through us
now for all of you we had about 600
because on my channel we had over 400
you had about 130 all of you here go to
Miles Channel
subscribe like the video there and watch
and support because he's the leading
Authority decimating this cult it is a
Blasphemous cult they're not really
trinitarians and may the Lord preserve
him provide for his ministry provide for
him Ministry and bless us for the glory
of Christ so brother thank you man I'll
be back next week you let me know Lord
willing I'm here amen and thank you all
for being here as well may Christ richly
bless you in the grace and peace won by
Christ and his vicarious death on the
cross for Sinners Hallelujah maratha
until next time amen
[Music]